the pandemic make some changes in our
general plan but not on the direction
so concerning the uh preparation you
know this this time we are recruiting uh
completely different let's say players unlike only
armenian team we also include parham we include uh
raunak we include we have a hike we have a tigran
of course i i taught them to be prepared against
the special specific opponents like grieschuk
and they are now at the moment working looking
on opening preparing some novelties and some
traps but anyway this is not as deep when you are
preparing with the team the only thing that can
be we can beat that these uh strong teams is the
hard-working if we will not spend time
on especially openings and etc basically
we do not have any chances first of all what
is the difference between average team and
uh team real team when there is a team character
it's a stability and i think in our team and it's
also by some way especially in chess we could see
armenian like team working team period exists and
this is this makes us a bit more responsible
hike without any problem is doing tremendously
well in this tournament speed uh championship and
also uh tremendously well in a title tuesday so
and considering all the strengths and the latest
results i think that at the moment hike uh is one
of the key engines which could uh from i mean from
his play we depend a lot in this kind of matchups
at the moment these these guys are younger
than 20 and working really hard to show uh
chess communities that they are very competitive
and can beat the big names like karwanakrishuk and
etc i mean besides kikram pedro san who is an old
guy and friend of mine with whom we were playing
a while ago and uh so far i have very good
positive score against him but anyway uh the the
these three kids i'm are juniors and one
of the capitals uh from my point of view
i mean we also need to have some national let's
say testimony of these kind of lineups and
uh by taking that okay if you will play enough
games so like you are sargent already 40 games
or 34 games you played you can be recruited as a
national team member uh it's i understand but not
agree with that in each kind of events uh
there is a one surprise surprising result
so considering the probabilities the probabilities
that we need to lose against the chess bro either
any team yeah and saint louis should
win the china and also the general event
so if there is a one chance that in any kind of
event it will be one unpredictable result so i
am finding that saint louis should beat the china
and we will be the team with unpredictable result
so or the original plan is also to go as as
as the people's preference would like because
again i as i mentioned there are there are uh
two players who will play from their rooms at
least two players here raunak and park last
year when we before our departure to us
um the prime minister of armenia host
us and make a lot of wishes to us
to success to have a success in in a participation
and etc and uh to create uh or to create an
atmosphere for armenia to took a world chess
championship title whoever it will be is among
our national strategy in 2015 and which means
that a lot of budget locations will go on this
direction and you know chess is like a religion
in armenia like canada has a hockey ice okay as
a religion the same is in armenia so everybody
if you are grand master like israel has a higher
reputation among the population everybody will
come and have a greeting and say his support and
his or her support etc and i think that as as
the time will go the champions will be becoming
younger and younger in the in order to keep that
you need a youth school huge youth school with
huge investments in order to continue this track
but if of course we will analyze the history
yes uh gary gas paramount grand pedro
both has armenian roots um and we had
two almost champions one is the bahanian during
his good years quite competitive with karpov
one of our national treasures and also
levon aronian who was always second once uh
again ten years ago and etc like paul
kerris who was very good player but always
second and it has all come down to this the pro
chest league 2020 finals between the saint louis
archbishops and the armenia eagles i'm grand
master robert hess alongside me today is the
magnificent the marvelous anna rudolph anna
how you doing today you ready for an exciting
match i'm ready to be blushing again because you
always compliment me too much robert but thank
you so much for the warm words the welcoming
words i would like to welcome the viewers too
this is it the final showdown between the top
two teams and these two teams are here for a
reason i feel like robert if we look at the
previous seasons we have the two-time champion
and defending champions saint louis archbishops
and the 2018 champion armenia eagles three seasons
of protest league and the previous champions are
here today fighting for the year's title 2020
champion archbishops eagles what do you guys think
who will take the 20k first prize today wow it's
really hard to predict even though st louis has to
be the favorite on on paper we just heard from the
armenian manager their captain kind of the soul
of the team artok manuki on he was saying that
hike martyrosan is the engine that leads their
squad and they have so many talented youngsters
and before we get into the weeds here let's remind
everybody some who maybe knew about the format of
this each team will be using four players for st
louis it's pretty much the u.s olympic team with
the exception being that hikaru nakamura is not
in the squad but they will play each other board
one will start by playing board four working their
way up towards playing the opposing team board one
all games are the time control of ten
minutes plus a two second increment
uh win standard scoring you see there and tie
breaks well that's going to be interesting if
it is an 8 8 tie after the 16 games we will
then have a latter situation where the board
fours will pit off against each other and
then we'll see if uh you know who will reign
supreme once they get to the board ones and as you
mentioned on a 20k for first place big prize fun
big payday for one of these teams and second place
10k not so bad either right not bad at all and we
already know who took the 6k third place that was
the china pandas if we also bring up for a moment
our bracket how did these teams perform throughout
the playoffs you see their way all the way to the
finals the eagles took down the chess brows in
the semi-finals and the archbishops defeated
the china pandas we know that the pandas are
now the bronze medalists but today will be the
final show who will take the god these are the
two teams the top two teams defending champions
and 2017 champions stainless archbishops
facing the 2018 champions armenia eagles
and that armenian eagles squad led by the
aforementioned hike martirossian you see him in
the center of the frame there he is an extremely
talented youngster he's just 20 years old he's
playing the junior speed chess championship his
next opponent is the guy to his left in that image
parham maksulu from iran that those two players
looking to spearhead this lineup and with another
talented youngster rounding out the lineup in
roundup segwani and there is tigran petrossian not
the former world champion but named after named
an honor i'm sure of the world champion who is
such an important piece of armenian history
exactly but their opponent is none other than
the absolute favored by rating points fabiano
carrana the world number two world champion
challenger of the 2018 world champs championship
match against magnus crossland he is the top board
of the archbishops wesley saw number eight
by classical rating and also lanier dominguez
former world blitz champion and by rating of uh
the rapid system actually he's world number six
and their board for jeffrey zhang only 19 years
old but such a rising star of the united states
soon to be on the olympic team of the us
this squad is here to defend their title
can they do it here are the pairings for the first
round uh so here we see well actually these are i
guess not quite parents the first round these are
just the board order for each team uh you see that
fabiano caruana leading these st louis archbishops
but even jeffrey zhang on board four the former
world junior champion he is actually higher rated
in classical chess it's an important distinguished
distinction excuse me between classical and the
rapid and blitz type controls that we'll see today
but jeffrey jones is higher rated as board four
than armenia's board one and parham aksub so anna
i mean of course on paper we know that st louis
is the heavy favorite what chances do you give
armenia and how are they going to upset the
heavily favored st louis archbishops great
question robert i think what we heard from
artak is that they are of course well aware
of the fact that they are the underdogs here but
they have constantly been proving that they are
in the finals for a reason this is the third
time then they made it to the top four of the
pro chess league and each and every time they
were the underdogs in those earlier matches
too i think it's their team comedy there's team
team spirit fighting spirit that makes it always
um that they are actually capable of going against
the odds today this is the highest most difficult
odds to play against the top team of the protest
league all rated above 2 700 of rating points
crazy strong the stainless archbishops
we'll see if the eagles can do it
and to be fair to the eagles as you mentioned
they're always the underdog and they were the
underdog in the semi-final matchup against the
canada chess bras but raunic sedwani on board four
scored two and a half out of four now that is
a monster performance by somebody who is facing
the likes of alexander grishok and anish giri
world top 10 players so he's proven that he can
do it he can handle the elite of the elite of the
chess world and while he's facing world number two
car one he's facing top ten player wesley so and
linear dominguez as well he just showed a couple
days ago that he is not afraid and he can score
important points for the armenian eagle so ana
i i i don't know it's really important first
round game between roundnuck and fabiano carwana
if somehow rana can hold off the world number
two that bodes well for the evil's chances
exactly as you mentioned ronak was a key piece in
the victory over the chess bros he drew against
alexander grishouk and he beat annish geary so
two two top ten players there as the opponents of
ronak from the previous match can he do it against
the world number two it's to be the first very
important question as well as hike martirosian
mentioned by the captain of the army eagles as
the engine of the armenian eagle so we shall see
how these two players will do today and of course
the entire squad no one can have a bad day today
if they want to make it no they cannot afford
anybody to you know collapse and well the weight
of this pressure here it's such a strong lineup
that they're facing but they need that team spirit
they need the consistency that they've shown
throughout the season where instead of having one
board go 4-0 it's really been a matter of you know
two and a half on a couple boards then about
two in the middle boards and they just really
help each other out uh there's no weak link in
the lineup all of them are worthy competitors
and i see that in the chat ana there's a lot of
armenia eagles emotes being spread exactly so
many fans of the eagles in the chat and also of
course the archbishops i see that logo as well
we are looking at the chat both on twitch as well
as on chess tv so make sure that you participate
as much as you would like to and i'm gonna keep
an eye on both shits during the match uh this is
gonna be the liftoff in two minutes we already
see the k the cameras of course of the players
ready set go wesley is the only one that has
abandoned his seat maybe he's looking for his
cat it has been it has been a very um successful
companion for wesley i must say whenever he had
his cat around he did play very well too that
is certainly the case and it's very strange to
see wesley so on board three but that's the
that's what happens when you face this top
heavy lineup of the archbishops five minute car
one number two in the world he has nowhere else
to go but board one unless magnus carlsen is on
his team dominguez such a superstar in the quicker
time controls i will say though that dominguez has
struggled at times throughout this uh summer and
the pandemic when he's been playing in many of
these online events we see him rise the top in
some and then struggle in others so i it depends
on what linear we see and i'm a huge fan i have so
much respect for linear's chess but i just have to
be honest that there have been moments throughout
this this pandemic in all these online tournaments
where i've been a bit concerned about dominguez's
play so ana i don't know what you make of that but
that may be one player where armenia hopes that
he's having an off day and they can pounce on
that board i fully agree with you and he's such
a strong player rated number six in the world by
rapid rating former world blitz champion but i
wonder if he's still not that accustomed to online
chances some of the other participants of course
they have all been playing a lot online but it's
one thing to play on your anonymous account as a
practice and another is to face the world's very
best in these events including the magnus carlson
chess tour and now the pro chess league where
we see the games starting right now and rhonda
said one he gets the white pieces against fabiano
carbona we mentioned this as a pretty key match-up
for the eagles because they want roundup to
continue his upward trend he did not lose to
those world top 10 players against the chess brows
here he has the white pieces we'll take our four
board view as you see on screen now and anna we
see two games that have started with e4 and then
two other games where there's a fianchetto boards
two and four fianchetto bishops on g2 boards one
and three we have e4 opening so what do you make
of the initial stages here i think it's a solid
start and no one will really go for dubious risky
openings this is the championship match so we will
likely see some of the most popular openings
chosen both by white and black in most of the
games i don't i don't think we're going to see
teams candy or the other kind defense as they did
in some of the earlier earlier saint louis
events for instance or the magnus carlsen tour
i think we could start with fabiano carrano as
you mentioned he's facing the youngest player of
the field ronak sadvani who performed really well
against the chess bras well it will depend a lot
for the eagles on his performance today if they
have a chance for the gold or not certainly will
and we see right now that five on his last move
bishop to c5 hits this knight on d4 and already
asking rounek an important question are you going
to either capture on c6 or remove the knight or
are you going to play bishop to e3 defending
the knight on d4 but i get the feeling that
there's okay he does take on c6 it's going to
say there might be some tactics in the position
that veronica would like instead he takes on
c6 fabiano takes back and if i'm not mistaken
black probably wants to play e5 in the future
and open up this bishop on c8 i do think that's
what black is aiming for indeed and white can't
do much about it because the f pawn is pinned
by the c5 bishop so f4 is out of the options i
do think that after e5 bishop e6 black will be
comfortable but it still takes two moves to get
that set up so let's see if white can do anything
about it for instance what happens if white played
knight a4 to annoy the bishop or bishop g5 does he
threaten to take on f6 double the pawns after
e5 yeah it's a very important question because
if you allow those double pawns it makes castling
much more difficult for black so i think that it's
unlikely that fabiano will play e5 but you were
honestly getting to this point that if you can
create a move that stops e5 directly maybe you
have enough time to prevent it all together and
for fabiano has to figure out do i move my
knight away do i drop my bishop back to e7
it's a bit of a passive move on it but maybe
that's what black's position calls for right now
it could be the case indeed that he may need to
spend the move to drop the bishop back be very
solid and not allow the doubling of his pawns
that would weaken the king side pawn structure
i wonder if fabiano will go for it or will he
just claim e5 allow bishop takes f6 at least
the structure changes and he will have the pair
of bishops that's true pair of bishops but the
weak pawns not an easy thing to assess here
and that's why fabiano is spending some time
and while he does so why don't we hop on over to
another game and whoa actually he just played h5
in aggressive response here by fabiano i do think
that maybe it's not quite as vicious as it might
immediately look i don't see how you get an attack
with this move but perhaps there's a future like
knight to g4 pawn h4 type of stuff and an attack
can build itself i'm not sure this definitely has
surprised me i didn't say h5 coming i also thought
he may go bishop e7 or e5 they were the two main
moves in my opinion but h5 is more ambitious i
like the ambition there by the world number two
and i wonder how rona could respond to this move
because it doesn't feel like this is the best move
here for black objectively speaking but certainly
it creates an interesting position where uh
the 15 year old will be tested for sure yeah he
certainly will be and i don't believe in it but as
you're saying can create some practical chances
and ranek is spending time so fabiano probably
off to the start he wanted let's uh hop on over
to the game between wesley so and hike marti
rossian marty rosen was hyped up as being the
engine for the armenian eagles and as i look at
both the board and the evaluation bar the engine
off to the left of the board here it says zeros
but this isn't just a symmetrical position
with no life left on a two bishops for black
but the knight and bishop and in particular is
an annoying knight on a5 for white what do you
make of this position uh i'm i'm just conf very
confused for a moment because i thought i saw
a result already but that must be there must be a
previous game obviously so so i'm gonna just stop
freaking out i thought wesley so has finished his
game but no he played the game right before the
match which showed up on my feed as his game so he
did win his practice game just to inform everybody
but not his current one okay i'm with you now
robert and i'm gonna stop freaking out for games
that are not part of the pro chess league but i i
also agree with you on the on what you said about
the zero zero zero this isn't uh a boring jewish
equal position there's plenty of play here three
possible results still i would say i i'm with you
there and black has this isolated pawn on e5 and
this knight on a5 it can't actually move anywhere
just yet if you move to c4 black will gladly
take that on c4 and ruin your pawn structure
so the knight is stuck here but it's also very
annoying here because i can't play b6 without
dropping the pawn on c6 and i can't move my rook
from b8 without dropping the pawn on b7 so for
the time being and well for the foreseeable future
this knight is going to stay here and be a bother
for black so on a i think at this point if i were
hike i would be considering bishop to b4 at
some moment just to even think about taking
this knight and going to opposite colored bishops
but as hikaru showed against magnus carlsen
in the magnus tour finals just because you've
opposite bishops on the board does not mean
it's just an easy draw in fact this would be a
tough position for black after say bishop to b4
bishop i was thinking bishop d2 and if you take on
a5 you're still left with these pawns cemented on
dark squares and that could be a problem for black
fully agree with you on that and i'm also just
quickly checking the other two boards in this
match um if there's anything that we have missed
so far i find the game between tigran petrossian
and lanier dominguez also very instructive
this pawn structure it was a king's indian attack
out of the opening but they are already a move
19 so we should probably just jump in and
evaluate what's going on in this middle game
whoa there's a pawn on g5 so clearly there
was a trade there the h4 pawn lands and anna
you have a lot of experience playing the french
as black and sometimes in the french in these
kings indian attack positions this is what you
get where black is trying to barrel through
on the queen side and white is saying hey i
have this pawn on g5 which is a double pawn
maybe you don't like double pawns but it does open
up this h file so what white would like to do is
move the king up to g2 at some point bring the
rook over to h1 and attack but that seems pretty
far off at least for the time being and maybe it's
more about this d4 pawn on it i think that as you
said at the moment an h-file attack is unlikely
but the d4 pawn is a target in black's camp
currently it is the queen on b6 that has to be
protecting it usually you don't want to tie down
your queen to the defense of a pawn so i'm curious
if black will manage to either trade the b3 knight
chase it away or play a knight maneuver such
as knight b8 knight c6 oh and it's happening
to protect the bomb with a less valuable piece you
don't want your queen to be defending forever that
was you know you you called it you knew exactly
what's going to happen and rerouting the knight
from d7 to c6 now what that does do is it takes
away a potential defender from the king because
the knight on d7 could go to f8 and defend this
h7 pawn so if this knight does come to c6 which it
looks like it will is white going to try for some
kind of king f2 rook h1 and use the open h file to
his advantage i don't know if it's quick enough
it does seem a bit slow you know you don't have
enough attackers there just yet but that's what
i'm looking at on as a way to get on over to the
h file now that you have no pieces ready to defend
your king yes i'm a little worried for that black
king on g8 to let's see if tigran petrossian will
find a way to start an attack on the king side
how do you bring your pieces the fastest possible
robert what would you say as a potential plan
yeah it's pretty slow king f2 rook h1 then what
it takes a while to get your next piece into the
attack and especially with the c2 pawn being such
a target you don't have time so maybe i mean maybe
this queen f2 which spies in the d4 pawn can
play g4 maybe even f5 if you want to go full
steam ahead it's a risky proposition for white but
i don't think that you can just sit back relax and
do nothing because then linear is kind of a5
a4 kicking this knight off from b3 and making
progress on the queen side feels pretty obvious f5
played right away and a5 played by linear this is
a fight on opposite sides of the board anna it
is i did like your queen of two move a lot for
the fact that it it would be tying down both the
knight and the queen of black to the defense of
the pawn but f5 is more aggressive and
lanier is just ignoring it he's saying
i'm not worried about that capture on e6 i'm
not worried about f6 either he well the capture
happened now e6 is hanging please rook to e8 the
good news for white is there's less pressure on
c2 and i would just go ahead and move my queen
to f2 that frees up the d2 square for the knight
and what you really want to do with this knight is
by knight to f4 this night we're on f4 black is in
huge huge trouble but it takes a long time to go
to c1 to e2 to f4 that's quite a journey it's not
like black is going to sit and do nothing but i do
think that he plays his queen e2 here comes knight
f knight d2 excuse me and then the knight can come
to f3 later and i don't think that black is out of
the woods just yet the bishop on h3 much better
than the counterpart on b7 which is behind a wall
of pawns yes very logical i think we'll come back
to this and see how the game develops but i would
like to jump back to boardroom for a moment
because it's chaotic all right let's go there
so the knight on h4 if we just take a look at
earlier how that trade happened that was a bishop
on h4 so basically we left the game um of fabi
when he pushed h5 that was a move 10. a lot has
happened since and uh black ended up being able
to capture the knight on the the bishop sorry on
h4 on move 17 after e5 knight takes h4 g
takes h4 f5 this is the current position
black's king is still in the middle of the board
and it's unlikely that faviano will want to castle
kingside the phone on h5 would be hanging plus now
with the rook on d1 he cannot cause so coincide
either at the same time the center is so closed
that it doesn't matter that he hasn't castled yet
his king is actually pretty solid and sheltered
on the e file that's true it looks like a bad
king we don't tend to like our kings and center
the board but it's safe and sound queen to e1
played by rana clearly trying to get to g3 and
protect the h4 pawn as well but this pawn g6 is
hard to pile pressure on i mean the king can just
come to f7 for black in which case g6 is defended
by the king and you're spending your queen's
energy trying to attack so i could see this in
a longer term position being favorable for black
because uh as the king gets sheltered you trade
off some pieces the bishop pair compared to the
knight and bishop it feels like the long-term
potential is in favor of the bishops i agree with
you i agree with you and now there are concrete
threats of course after um the queen moving to g3
the pawn on g6 was hanging i i do like i do like
the fact how ronak is not scared of this h5 push
and the very unique and creative way in which fabi
has been handling this game and he says i'm gonna
try to create some pressure on those vulnerable
spots such as the g3s the g6 square from the queen
on g3 um knight e2 just regrouping his pieces
i think this is a really unclear position but
the 15 year old board four of the army nagels is
certainly not scared of fabi no and he's holding
his own thus far we'll see how this one plays out
we do have results it was a draw between uh
parham xudulu and jeffrey zhang both of them
former world junior champions i'll just flash that
game on screen just to show you the final position
and then we'll return to this game here uh well
it was locked up they agreed on draw i think that
just from first glance white is probably slightly
better because that's an isolated pawn on d5
but maybe jeffrey was like my job here is to
stave off parham i don't necessarily need to
to beat him but i think that white's
fish looks really good at this point
i like white's position a lot as well i do think
that the d5 pawn will be an issue the evaluation
bar doesn't show that much of an advantage but
black's position is way more passive and we'll
we shall see how parham will try to rig up his
pieces will the bishop drop back to b7 you can't
really leave it on the background depending on the
defense of the d7 queen so this certainly is quite
a lot of pressure that jeffrey has been building
up and if we once again remind our viewers of
the format this game is board one of the eagles
versus board four of the archbishops and it is
board four of the archbishops that has taken
the initiative and is trying to win this game
yeah but they they actually agreed on draw so
that's that was the weird part about it is that
i liked jeffrey's position but they made it draw i
guess the time was a factor where parham had over
three minutes more than jeffrey but yeah still it
felt like a position where jeffrey could press and
let's go back to the games that are in session uh
fabiano's game against roenek now it's opposite
colored bishops which means that typically there
are increased drawing chances but with this pawn
on h4 a weakness maybe the pawn and f4 all these
are dark squares and black's pawns on the king
side at least easier to defend so it seems feels
like fabiano should be slightly better but nothing
too major just yet nothing too major um i
still i'm shocked that that game ended up
because i was hoping it would keep going i
still didn't see the result on my screen but
yes it is confirmed that it was a draw and we
shall see if the other three boards will bring
a result so do you see any other games here that
catch your eye because we've been in this fabiano
versus roundup game for a while why don't we
head on over to one of the others if uh there's
an interesting one there yes let me browse through
the games i think tigran petrossian has managed to
increase his advantage over lanier dominguez if we
take a look at that board too but for now the the
fourth board view uh does highlight the current
situation with one of the boards board four
uh jeffrey zhang has finished his game uh that's
a draw but the other three boards are still on i
think dominguez may be in trouble fabby's position
is still unclear and wesley isn't a rook and game
that is better for white but can he convert
it into a full point will be the question
there's an important one and i think your first
point about t grown against dominguez he runs up
two minutes on the clock his pieces are far more
active this bishop on h3 attacking a pawn on e6
the bishop one state stuck defending the f file
very important right now especially with queen f7
on the agenda and rook f8 was played and look
at how quickly secretly queen e7 let's trade
on the f1 square you're back rank anna and the
king on g has really no defenders helping it out
yes i'm really scared we were talking about that
black king being quite left alone and the default
pawn has disappeared since it was traded for the
c2 pawn so the structure has changed but the issue
with the black king is still the same i agree
with you that after queen e7 and this trade on f1
um now queen e8 is a threat of checkmate in one
and even if you prevent the maid by pushing one
of the pawns to have some escape square for the
king it still looks scary it looks very scary with
the queen giving a check on the backrank it may
not be decisive uh robert but it looks definitely
very very promising for white at the very least
why can you scoop off one of these pawns on the
queen side over here and honestly i mean queen i'm
trying to figure out which way to do this because
i can play queenie a check and just take b5 which
protects both b2 and d3 the issue i'm foreseeing
with something like that is white's king isn't
exactly that safe either not that it's going to
get checkmated but there could be many checks so
if i play okay he plays queen to d8 with check
but i was thinking if he had played oh let's even
go kg7 queen takes a5 i guess you can't take on b2
because there's queen c7 check so maybe tigran
actually found the best way to do this as once
the uh pawn is capturing a5 there's still threats
on the black king and this is maybe just almost a
winning position dare i say for tigran i think
that's a fair evaluation if black doesn't have
anything immediate now he will be in trouble
without that a pawn white will manage to create
the past pawn two versus one on the queen side
meaning that slowly but surely white will have a
past pawn eventually so the only chance for black
would be if there's something immediate now if if
he could go for a perpetual check but i think
after queen c to check the issue is white can
use the bishop to be placed on g2 and simply there
will be no more attack for that black queen bishop
d7 was played instead all right just showing
that the queen can't go anywhere without losing
the bishop so instead bishop came out and queen to
d8 and that attacks the bishop threatens queen f6
check in many variations and i think you can even
just play a slow move like d4 at any moment saying
that black can and he plays it black can't do
anything and maybe this queen is coming to c5
let's there it is there's queen c5 let's trade
the queens off on it you made the point outside
passpod for white and so now the question is the
precise way to move forward here black can hardly
do anything but queen is coming to f7 and once the
queen gets to f7 trying to get to f2 but now with
the [ __ ] when i said no no no this has to be
so good for tigran exactly and look at the time
difference too lanier down to his final 10 seconds
there is a two second increment but living off
of the increment is usually not a good sign still
three minutes for tigran but petrossian who has a
pawn up will try to create a passport on the queen
side has more space more activity for his pieces
everything is looking great for petrossian so we
could take a look at the other two boards and see
who which player of the archbishops will manage
to score if they lose on this board okay gonna
hop away from this game quickly we'll keep an eye
on especially as it is nearing the finish line
let's go on to the game between wesley so
and heike martin roseanne because that one
is down into a rook ending and at first glance
it looks just an extra pawn for white but with
so few pawns remaining on it there are chances
especially if you take on h4 here comes rook to
g4 and i win one of the pawns back so it's just
going to be one extra pawn for white is it enough
good question if it's enough um we certainly see
that wesley so is trying his best he did not take
on h4 but gave the check first i wonder i wonder
why he found this more precise this move order
with the check and pushing the black king to e6
yeah it's interesting because the king on e6 looks
i guess it's separated from the c6 pawn so that's
really the major plus but how do you actually get
to the c6 pawn because if you bring your king up
you drop c2 if you move your rook and try to take
you drop f3 and at some point you're gonna have to
do something because black is just sitting on the
position going to shuffle the king back and forth
leave this rook on f2 where it attacks both pawns
at the same time and i mean how does white proceed
here maybe there's rook c3 king b4 king c5 but
the black king will make its way back to d6 before
your rook and king can line up in perfect harmony
yeah certainly that would be a plan for
white we shall see if it will be carried out
all the games are on fire so i feel like we need
to be jumping a little bit back and forth because
fabian or karana the world number two with the
black pieces has managed to build up an attack
on the king's side wow and this king on g1 it's
like in danger being checked mid you could take
on h3 with check but if the queens come off ana
then that's what ronich really wants here so where
is the make bishop g3 is there a checkmate
coming it feels like there's one very close
yes it feels like bishop g3 should be the
move it is played now by fabiano bishop
b3 and evaluation bar has jumped fully yes
black's advantage just went really high here
so what happens after queen h2 check king to f1
like where's a queen h1 check the king runs to e2
let's i mean this is it's getting close
here he takes on h3 oh my gosh is this h
punk gonna queen is that what's gonna happen
no way i don't think so well it looks like a
potential plan but for now black will give a
couple of more checks to rigor their pieces
after king d2 bishop e1 where will that white
king go you're winning the queen yes yes and if
oh my god i was cutting you there because i was
shocked that this is indeed amazing that now
for instance uh bishop f to indeed queen div on
bishop e3 and then it's checkmate oh my gosh he
wins fabiano wins and you saw his face he was just
like like didn't expect that one to happen and
raunch unfortunately uh lost the game but tigrum
petrossian did win for the armenian eagle so it
is one and a half one half right now we just have
this wesley so end game remaining and wesley so
at this point looks like he is winning this game
up a second pawn he has managed to convert this
and now he just needs to push his pawns in tandem
yeah what a game what a turn of events in many of
these positions that we evaluated as unclear and
they all end up being decisive results it seems
uh robert what will happen in this
position this final position uh
after after the pawns are gonna guess i guess we
know the answer but still what what a play i'm
i'm still thinking of the earlier games tigran did
win his game and fabiano as well but the decisive
factor will be that wesley so has managed
to um basically get a full point out of a
better rooken game it was better for him but it
wasn't a completely winning position of course
earlier that's true we'll have an opportunity to
look through these games in a few we're gonna take
a short break and when we return we will highlight
what just happened in round one get ourselves
ready for round two and the same was archbishops
are out to a two and a half one and a half lead
you will not want to miss the remaining
action of the pro chess league finals
the players were doing everything in the
blink of an eye but we did have the break
to look at some of these critical moments from
the first round of action and anna in the game
between fabiano caruana and ronak sedwani
a very critical game and a critical moment
it looks like according to the engines that
raunic sedwani's position was acceptable and
the reason why is he's up a couple pawns
black's king is safer than whites but
is potentially susceptible to a bunch of checks
but what roundneck did with bishop to b3 cost him
the game instead i think you could explain
why move like bishop to d5 or bishop to c4
would have kept him according to the evaluation
in a level position i feel like that bishop is
important when it comes to the defense of the
white king so when you place it on d5 or c4 it
still has the potential of coming back to g2 or f1
and it won't only be the queen on d4 that's taking
care of some of those really critical squares
around the white king on g1 so that's definitely
one plus over the bishop going back to b3 which
was i believe in the heat of the time pressure
to protect the c2 pawn but that pawn is not really
important white is already a couple of pawns up
as you have mentioned so it was more important to
give back some of the material but save the king
and then after bishop d5 of bishop c4 white will
also have couple of checks once you have your king
safe and sheltered exactly the bishop moves
out of the way of the pawn so you can e6 type
of check and that pawn can even try to become a
queen so black's king not super safe either and
likely this position uh should just be some kind
of like repetition you check you bring the bishop
back to g3 which threatens another mate on h2
so the king would likely have to scoot back
uh to g1 or otherwise white's not making any
progress so a missed opportunity there for
raunic we can hardly blame him it was in time
trouble and when he played bishop to b3 as you
said on protecting c2 but unfortunately his king
lacks any sort of safety and so fabinho was able
to quickly win from this position uh with czech
so just give a bunch of checks and the king has
nowhere to go after queen f1 cannot escape and the
bishop comes to e1 taking over the other diagonal
just a winning position for black it's such an
instructive position the final moves how the
bishop and the queen are collaborating in a way
that the black queen is controlling all the light
squares and the back rank and the bishop joins
in on the dark squares so white has no way out
of losing this game if king e3 then the bishop
will pick up the queen of the bishop f2 check
and it should be checkmate two in a few moves
but i think this is resignation moment and what
happened in the game instead was also really
beautiful the tactical motive after king c1
bishop f2 check and queen to d1 cannot save
the day because bishop e3 check will push the
king away from the protection of the queen and
then it's backrank mate yeah so really beautiful
harmony between black's pieces and white's pieces
were not doing quite the same so a good win in
the end there by fabiana carwana and speaking
of good wins tigran petrossian had a great win
against leonardo dominguez and he's the reason
that armenia remains in the match anna you talked
a long time before this moment about the outside
pass pawn for white and how because black can
hardly do anything that white should just be able
to press on and that's exactly what tigran did is
he went a4 in this position and black was just
completely stuck and couldn't really do anything
yes it's really a sad story because it is the
outside passport and the king the black king on g7
is constantly under attack queen f6 bishop
takes e6 is always in the air so the black queen
cannot really go away from the sixth rank and
from the protection of the king the bishop on f7
is a very passive piece it's basically a tall
pawn on f7 not doing much but protecting e6
exactly and this moment where um tigran played
a5 he said hey go ahead and take the pawn i'ma
just explain exactly why you're gonna have
a problem with this queen f6 check the king
has to go back to g8 and then you can take on e6
so the e6 pawn falls and once e6 falls it's not
just about the one pawn i get a pass pawn so after
you trade on e6 my king always has shelter on h3
your king is just in harm's way and just to finish
this one off let's say you try to go to e8 or g it
doesn't really matter i can just play pawn to e6
which allows me to play pawn to e7 and your king
is absolutely stuck here not getting out of this
and so white is just winning so a nice win there
by tigran petrossian and finally on a wesley
sew showing off that end game technique
at this moment he had a problem with the pawn on
f3 and the pawn on c2 he says yeah i don't care
about that rook takes c6 and if you took on f3
the white king comes into d5 and e5 is in trouble
that was indeed the key motive the
way in which wesley managed to get
a better endgame converted into a full point and
i believe after uh yes exactly those checks and
the king coming in once the e5 bomb falls this
position is winning connected past bones four
white and black can do nothing to stop them yeah
it's a very good understanding and realization by
wesley to say that you know i doesn't even matter
if i lose what looked like a very important pawn
f3 because the white king gets in so fast there's
no way for black to defend this pawn the only way
would be king f4 but i play king d5 defending and
attacking and i have rook f6 check to kick your
king off of the square so i can win the e5 pawn
so a nice win there by wesley he helps saint louis
to the two and a half a one-half lead and before
the next round begins i know we do have to remind
people of a pretty special thing they can do they
can very important indeed because september is
about to be over time is flying but only three
more days until which you can save up to 30 on
your subscriptions on twitch so take advantage
of september because each and every year
twitch hell holds hosts basically a september sale
but it's only in the month of september so three
more days and it's gone until the year 2021. well
that's sad it's it goes away and in which case
you just gotta pay full price nobody likes that
but anna we have the second round coming up here
we have uh some i guess more closely rated
matchups in the middle and the two and the
uh three seeds you know they're doing well and so
like when we look at these matches fabiano plays
against tigran both players won their game you
have lenier who lost taken of roundup who also
lost we have wesley with white uh so i don't
know if actually he's with the white pieces but
he takes on para maksudu and so wesley should
have the black pieces actually because parham
was just black and wesley was just a white and
then we have jeffrey zhang with the black pieces
against hike marti rosen so what do you make of
these four match-ups it's gonna be once again a
difficult round for the eagles as it will be
every single time for the fact that the the
rating average of the archbishops is way
higher you already said two that jeffrey
zhang is higher rated than board one of the
eagles so every round um we go into the games
seeing the eagles being the underdog but this
has been the case for so many of their matches
and they keep proving that they can go against the
odds i wonder if petrossian can can keep up with
the level he has been showing so far his opponent
will be the world number two not an easy opponent
to face for sure and for the rest of the team
from armenia they need to pull themselves together
and take down some of their higher rated opponents
if they want a shot at the champions title
they certainly will need to bounce back right
now and the matchup that i'm particularly looking
forward to is this one between dominguez and
sanwani because both players lost their first game
and of course they both want to strike back
but you can't get in this mindset if you have
the psychology of i need to win the game you're
no longer playing chess and you just have this
results-oriented thinking that can really backfire
and hurt your chest so when i look at that
match-up of course linear is the favorite he's
the much higher rate of the two players but rauna
you know he's tough we mentioned his performance
against the candidate chess perez he's not just
going to say oh i'm out of this i lost that first
game he lost the fabiano caruana i mean come on
that's the number two player in the world and he
was just a couple accurate moves away from saving
that game so that's where my focus is what other
games do you have uh circled for this next round
i was going to highlight the dominguez game
as well for the fact 2 that is a clash of
generations it's the oldest participant of
today's match versus the youngest i believe
there's two decades of age gap between the two
so very different style when also when it comes
to how they learn to play jazz how they manage
to keep improving their skills but other games
obviously jeffrey jean versus hike martirosian
two of the top junior players in the world
ken martirosian upset jeffrey shank who has been
playing really well so far for the archbishops
yeah it's a really tough question i mean
jeffrey that guy doesn't lose very often he's
such a talented player and as we have the four
board view all of these st louis cameras there
we see a car con board one we see us
spanish on board two we see uh d4 on
boards three and four i sense a theme today
on that's gonna be a split between e4 and d4
yes uh i also i'm just quickly glancing through
as you said all those opening positions and
i wonder i wonder how long the preparation of
tigran petrossian will go in this variation of
the caricom that we see on board one that that
is that is a test from the world number two
trying to show his uh very best skills
against the karakan we have seen this
opening a couple of occasions also
at the saint louis rapid and blitz
i wonder if petrossian has something up
his sleeve because these positions can be
really uncomfortable for black unless you play
the most precise way yeah these positions here
you see that the queen's at a6 and magnus did
this against hikaru in the was the same lewis
rapid where he did that i'm mixing all my events
together i wasn't sure if there was the magnus
toward finals or the same those rapid but i
think it was the same was rapid and this is
becoming increasingly popular with the queen on
a6 the point is that you have some pressure down
on this diagonal through the pawn c4 to the queen
on d3 and eventually you want to poke and prod at
this pawn on d4 so tigran playing very quickly
on a seems like he's in relative preparation
it does feel like that he still has a
bit more time than fabiano so it looks
promising when it comes to seeing how well
prepared he came to today's match now after a3
the bishop has to go bishop takes d2 would be one
of the main options here but he started thinking
now which is interesting i like bishop takes d2
and i mean i think it's hard for many viewers
and really just all of us to determine
when do you give a bishop for a knight
this is a very closed position so the knights have
this potential now it may not be obvious right
away but they have this potential and especially
this knight on f5 that's on a light square
it's very difficult for you to kick this knight
out because you're a dark square bishop and black
controls the g4 square so the knight f5 looks
very good here five minor captures back with the
bishop on d2 maybe trying to get around to b4 that
looks like a pretty useful diagonal but is it time
anna it's a tough decision to make but is it
time for c5 for tigra i think he's thinking of
it and he has played it very quickly too so
he considered it for a very short time and
and said to us yes robert it's time it's the right
moment for it and i think it's clear that it's
the right moment because the queen still pins this
pawn on c4 you would love and just forget that the
queen is hanging you'd love to be able to take on
d5 because the pawn on e6 can't take back as the
995 is hanging but as we mentioned the queen on a6
has pinned the pawn to the queen on d3 so you're
not getting away with that capture and if that's
the case i would wouldn't mind you capturing me on
c5 because as is typical in the french and
the caricon now your e5 pawn is also more
vulnerable and so i can just take back on c5
and later turn my attention to your pawn on e5
yes indeed i believe that is the issue now
if white was gonna take on c5 and it feels
like if white could open up the position it should
favor white because the black king is still in the
middle of the board but as you showed knight takes
c5 with a tempo and there's no direct line in
which white could take advantage of the king being
still uncastled and right now the king can't oh as
soon as that's about to say it the king can castle
it does castle and this tension in the center
seems to favor black for the time being and it's
pawn a3 even though you don't want to capture it
right away because that is a free pawn in the
sense that you can take it and white can't take
a pawn back immediately your queen a might get
trapped over there and more importantly it's going
away from the rest of the action so sometimes
those pawns are poisoned you really don't want
to pay attention to that pawn especially when your
king was still in the center fully agreed fully
agreed it does look like tigran petrarcian has
come to this game very well prepared and he isn't
scared of fabiano's potential world championship
and rest of the elite tournament preparations when
facing the carrick and defense he he sticks to his
main repertoire and this currently is an unclear
position which gives us time to look at the rest
of the boards as well in this round two match up
where the archbishops are leading with one point
but the eagles i believe are ready to fight back
they always believe in their chances even when
a point or two down they certainly do so uh why
don't we go over to the game between ronix and
money and linear dominguez a game that we both you
know we're very attentive to because we're like
both players lost in the first game it's going to
be a critical match up who can rebound and we see
a berlin so we're probably both not too excited
this queenless position in the berlin and well
very clearly black has these double pawns on the
c file but has the bishop pair and light square
bishop that white does not have what white has
done lanier has rerouted his knights potentially
to come to the d4 square and typically you want to
play g4 put your pawn to f4 and try to get f5
to happen but with knight on f3 and bishop f4
i don't know that seems very far away at this
point it does seem far away i think this is
a solid position yes we aren't too excited about
seeing the berlin again but anything can happen
with this time control so ten plus two ten minute
two second increment is the time control of the
protest league so i would predict that for now
this game will not be fireworks or big mistakes
but if we come back to it in a few minutes there
might be a different story so for now i think we
could leave this as a roughly equal position where
both players are still doing fine who may not be
doing fine i'm afraid uh is like martyrosian when
it comes to the eagles and their chances because
he does have divide pieces against jeffrey jean
but in opposite side counseling positions it's all
about who gets to attack the opponent king faster
and you see the black bones already marching
forward toward the white kingdom b1 while for
white white does have a semi-open h5 but it's only
the rook that is for now attacking on the king
side yeah this is an important dynamic to note the
rook on h1 it looks great that looks like the best
attacking piece in the position but you're talking
about the potential that if black can continue
marching those pawns forward especially with the
pawn a3 now that's a hook so if you play rook f
to b8 or a to b i'm not sure which is better but
then try to get b5 to b4 that could be really
a disaster for white but say we see a trade and
well speaking of disasters this bishop on g7 could
cause a disaster for white as well because that's
a long diagonal and only one side has a dark
square bishop i'm really scared of the g7 bishop
it does such a good job when it comes to defending
the king on g8 and at the same time attacking the
king on b1 goes to show the long range feature of
bishops and that is a beast of a bishop for sure
as you already highlighted why it does not have a
dark squared bishop anymore so there's no chance
of placing white's bishop on d4 and somehow
trading the g7 bishop this is i believe the
key feature of the position and that's why marty
rossian is getting into trouble i wonder if he can
somehow get out of this window his way out of the
game but for now looks very promising for jeffrey
yeah you would need some kind of counter
a bishop f3 type of move but unfortunately
two black pieces defending the d5 pawn so i'm
looking at the d5 pawn as a potential weight oh
it means knight v5 okay so he's actually removing
one of the defenders very clever by hike he's
trying to get after the d5 pawn but it will take a
bit of time because knight takes b5 like let's say
we just trade and you go bishop takes d4 which is
looking kind of obvious for black to steal a pawn
then i guess there's some kind of bishop c6 and
the d5 pawn the a4 pawn the a8 rook maybe there's
a little bit of a problem there for black that's
that should be his idea but yes it's a brave move
if it works as you showed with bishop c6 and the
d5 pawn hanging later on then this should be the
best move the best response because he is trading
this um important c7 knight which was supporting
the push of the b pawn as well and the knight on
c3 was going to get into trouble plus the d4 pawn
had no protection so he may have just found a
very precise way of keeping the position together
yeah that was a interesting move knight b5 did
not come to my mind i freely admit that but it
makes things complicated it was starting to get a
little bit too simple for jeffrey and you must be
sure that hike was looking at the initial position
right before knight to b5 and saying wait if i
take on c5 then this pawn can take back and now
i've opened the b file the bishop is open i mean
i'm just getting rolled over here you can't afford
that and so hike coming up with a clever resource
to at least give him some chances here yes i do
think that this is a great practical chance we
both miss knight b5 as an option and while the
position for blacks should still be better it
may not be as problematic as it seemed earlier
yeah i mean really nice find there by hiking
this is big not just for him but his teammates
because they would likely are looking at each
other's games like oh hike's position looks
really bad with the white piece and now all
of a sudden you're like wait okay now i have
to calculate and as soon as you start getting
that mentality of all right it's not so simple
for me to calculate it's not simple for jeffrey
then things start to improve as a team and so
the knight went actually back to e8 and now the
knight on b5 defends d4 that's a weird little
outpost for the knight on b5 so all of a sudden
maybe knight d3 and then knight to e5 like white
can start trying to make some progress of his own
i do like those nine maneuvers that you are
showing i'm not a huge fan of knight to e8 i feel
like this knight is standing too well on b5 so
you will want to get rid of it at some point but
i believe jeffrey's idea is to keep the position
more complex and he wants his knight on e4
what a position this is now it's getting very just
like it's stuffy in the center of the board there
are a lot of pieces here there's some tension on
c5 and d4 that's not that big of a deal at least
not yet and maybe bishop f3 now so if you go to
e4 i can consider taking you and i do want to play
g4 at some point i just can't get away with it
yet you have too many pieces covering the square
i'm quickly checking what happened in the
meantime on the boards we have already looked
at and there's of course still a game we haven't
checked in with that wesley so with the black
pieces against former world junior champion
parham maxulou so should we go on to that
game since we haven't looked at it i think just a
quick check in and see how the position is because
it's not the typical symmetrical equal position
that we could expect this definitely is
um going in a unique way where both white and
black have con basically connected past pawns
protected past bones of their owns but so far
neither of them can start pushing those pawns
it's such a weird looking position and part of the
reason why you're mentioning the past pawns and
white's pawns are on light squares which is good
in the sense that they restrict the bishop on b7
so that bishop b7 doesn't look so good but the
problem with it is that means they're easier
to attack in a sense because they're on light
squares so i'm very curious about how this one
will develop and look at bishop b3 trying to get
knight c4 remove the blockading queen queens are
horrendous at blocking past pawns because they're
so easy to attack you want to block kade to pass
palm with a knight because the knight can see over
the palm it attacks things that are behind that
pawn the knight on c4 for white stops this past c
pawn and would have attacked the queen and so can
i play e5 now on it like oh no i can't i'm just
hanging upon never mind never mind i got excited
i was like wait your queen moved away i'll play
e5 no that's me blundering do not play e5 that's a
horrible move maybe not e5 but there certainly are
tactical motives i'm even thinking of e takes f5
which is structurally a move we don't want but uh
if we trade the queens isn't white just a pawn up
yep so take on g6 and that's an extra pawn it's
pretty annoying pawn too because it keeps the
black king boxed in with background checkmate
ideas yes i do think that maxo lou is taking the
initiative here and also the material advantage
will wesley find a way in which he can somehow
get that pawn back currently he has to deal with
the hanging rook on e3 either has to take on e1
or move that rook away back through the e5 or
rook to d3 that could be an active choice but
as you said that phone on g6 is so annoying there
will be back rank threats background checkmate
threats constantly and the rook coming into e7 i
think parham has a great chance of taking down one
of the top players of the archbishops yeah you you
know you looked at those past pawns from the start
you're like oh those pawns look pretty dangerous
black's pawns don't look dangerous and even though
white lost the connectivity of the e4 d5 pawn the
d5 pawn still defended and as we see moves now
uh he played here the rook came to e7 giving
up the d2 knight for the d7 night the king on
h8 isn't in great shape so parham really playing a
nice game with a lead on the clock as well so that
bodes well for his chances and i think we should
take a step back for a second here let's do our
full board for board view here just so we can see
all the action at the same time we're just talking
about the game underneath wesley so there where
wesley's in trouble he looks like he's in trouble
based on his sort of angle and facial
expression jeffrey looking very focused
fabiano just looks kind of calm honestly and
linear psi eyeing the board i think that is indeed
what we can read from the body language i was
also looking at perham's camera earlier because
it felt like he was talking but i do think
it's not it's not just talking it to himself
i i think he's singing if we can get back her
camera on on perform for a moment or the eagles
as a ford board view i don't know if we have that
sorry i'm asking for something that wasn't ready
yet um let's just go back to what we have for
now apologies but i i do think that uh parham
is enjoying the music he's listening to apart
from having a great position against wesley so
yeah parham often is listening to rap
and he's just like bopping his head and
he's really having the time of his life he
loves chess and he clearly loves his music so
his position still looks very good i would not say
that it's anywhere close to over definitely not
the knight on f6 the bishop one five we're talking
about the bishop one b7 didn't look so good the
bishop on f5 now attacks g6 and it also will try
to venture to d3 at some point i imagine to help
the pawns push forward so wesley is fighting back
though parham remains better i just saw a result
it looks like raunek saguani with the black
pieces held off leonardo dominguez they made a
draw in that game so i'll pull up
the final position just very quickly
to show you and why was this game a draw
well it looks like the bishop came to d5
and interestingly enough a draw was offered
by saadwani i imagine and linear took it
because black is taking over the a file and if
the colors were reversed i have a feeling that
linear would have played on with the black pieces
and that's why he accepted a draw with white
he felt like his position was slightly worse i
believe so there's a rating difference of over
250 points so ronak thought this is a good
result it is a good result for his team but
there remains like the question whether he should
have been a bit more ambitious than just aiming
for the draw and play on there are still three
more games on the way um fabiano caruana with the
white pieces does have a very promising position
again will we see another checkmate pattern that
king on h7 isn't very secure oh yeah some kind of
knight g5 but how does he make it work because you
need to get your rook to h8 as well but the king
was actually running up the board for black well
bring this on the analysis board really quickly
because that's a crazy position where after king
h7 knight g5 king h6 rook h8 would be made but the
knight's hanging knight f7 check do not go back to
h7 because then rook h8 is checkmate so you know
by process of elimination your king would have to
go up the board and after rook h a check well my
knight can actually come back to block i can even
play king to g4 and somehow the king is safe on g4
like running to f4 running into the center of the
board it's not getting mated but knight h6 clearly
was the better choice just keeping the king safe
and sound it is a crazy position and it does seem
like fabiano has made a mistake it was not easy
to see with all the knight g5 check king h6 king
march what was the best for white but certainly
rook c1 is criticized by the engine
our evaluation bar has suddenly dropped
and is now showing decisive advantage for black i
don't believe in it you know queen c4 oh stopping
queen c1 check that's very important like queen
c4 there were no other squares to use so queen
c4 says you're not getting this check and black
can even consider g5 and g4 because the king on
h6 cannot be attacked with just one lone knight
over here you need to get more pieces in the
game than rook on d5 the queen on c4 say no
you're not getting anything nothing for you
wow that is an absolutely crazy turn of events
from a position where it looked like fabiano
was creating a checkmate net around the black
king it is now the white king that will end up
being in a trouble after g5 g4 where does the
knight go rookie for to attack the queen but
even if you just play queen to c3 the threats
will remain not g4 because the rook on e4 is
taking care of the g4 square but this suddenly
looks so suspicious for the world number two
chances for the armenian eagles to strike back
this is a huge moment here and tigran won the
first round game against leonardo dominguez and
right now after rookie four he's sitting he's
thinking do i play queen d3 which forces the
queens off the board because your rook's under
attack your queen's under attack if you'd like
queen to e1 at queen d1 and off go the queens
and black is actually up upon in the initial
position they may be double pawns but one of
them is extra and so black in great shape and
fabiana caruana you see he's locked in trying
to figure out a way to save this game he lose 32
seconds left queen d3 is the choice of petrossian
which also is very logical even after
the trade of queens now the pawn on a3
is hanging he still has a healthy extra pawn
and very active pieces so how can fabiano
get out of this a verse end game where he is
under attack and it's down to 12 seconds now
i think he's lost and here at king h5 that way
you take away rook g4 and you play g4 yourself
i mean black is just pushing forward the g pawn
will come to g3 after that and maybe the white
king will get checkmated so here i believe this
this could still lead to checkmate indeed because
of g4 coming in now and after knight h2 g3 well
you can't take it you can't take it and now h3
then the pawn can't take on h3 because it's
night's hanging keep pushing those pawns
he missed him is the immediate h3 but still
the position has to be completely winning
as robert pointed out the g3 pawn couldn't be
taken because of knight g3 fork and after rook
a1 check knight e1 so many good moves here for
black the a4 pawn is hanging he can also take on
f2 if he wants or g5 keeps pushing and he can
always take on f2 if he's worried about some
something but there's nothing really to be worried
about at this point he goes rook a2 immediately
putting pressure on f2 the king can go to g4
it goes back to g6 that's smarter kg4 has this
fear that you might get checkmated right if this
king run g4 now f3 would be made if you can just
imagine the key there and black one on time wow
wow wow what a game by tigran petrossian taking
down the top board of the archbishops with the
black pieces this is the world number two world
champion challenger fabian ocarina going down with
the white pieces against an over 200 rating point
less rated opponent i know rating is not
everything but here is the eagles proving that
they can go against the odds they are turning the
tables also on the board of martyrosian against
zhong oh my gosh yeah right now you see the attack
on the h7 pawn it is black's turn white's king is
not exactly very safe either so anna we're
looking at this position this is anyone's
game do not go to the e file because rookie
would have pinned the queens that's why rook d2
was the blockading piece do not allow this queen
to come to f3 check so he takes on f4 i mean this
is just looking better and better for hike by the
move it does look great for white the evaluation
but it's almost fully white showing that there is
uh something concrete or also just the fact that
white is material up of course but white will most
likely end up getting even more although that bar
just sunk really quickly have i jinxed it i don't
think you quite jinx it but there was a move there
that was great for a hike this was not it says
zeros and that means that white probably needs to
be a little bit careful queen a3 check maybe this
is the the draw queen back from h3 to a3 that's a
weird looking draw it is a weird looking one but i
think jeffrey will go for it and that is an escape
for the archbishops in this game where jeffrey
had a better position after the opening he was
the one trying to play it for a win but the tables
turn and now it is hayek who missed a winning
opportunity um it was um an earlier moment where
where he could have played a different variation
we will show it to you guys later on but for now
this seems to finish in a draw soon while the
other game where the eagles have a lead perhaps
max would do with a pawn up against wesley so
could also end in a draw in this knight end game
oh you see jeffrey shook his head he's was upset
with himself he had a better position earlier
on but we'll look at that later we're gonna
keep our eyes on this oh my gosh knight and two
against knight in one these are so difficult to
defend often on a because if the knights ever get
traded then black is going to lose the end game
yes for that reason black is keeping the knights
on the board and now it is active king on f4 i
don't think that white has a way to make progress
if knight check on d3 or h3 then king g4 king d3
instead but black will keep the king on f4
creating a blockade and there is no real way
in which white can make progress what black
is doing now is to trade the remaining pawn
that he has and then he could sacrifice
the knight for the last pawn of white
exactly and white was forced to trade because
otherwise that knight was coming into f3 to win
the pawn so we see that this position all black
needs to do is trade the knights or trade the
knight for the pawn either would be a draw we see
a draw so that round was won by the armenia eagles
two and a half one and a half thanks to their hero
tigran petrossian that is a shocking result tying
the score but it also feels like they may have
missed more chances maybe they could have taken
the lead in this match we will break down what
happened in those key games after a short break
so
the armenia eagles tied up the match
against the saint louis archbishops and
it was getting close to be a lead for the armenian
eagles on a this one you can hardly blame hike
martyrosy for not finding what is according to
the evaluation bar a completely winning move
can you imagine anna playing rook to d7 in
a position where king is so exposed on d1
it was a very difficult move to find he had 42
seconds on the clock to make this decision and
allowing queen age one jack with the rook hanging
on b1 it certainly is not obvious that this was
the winning at the best and most decisive winning
line four white he instead played the very natural
quindi for check but with that move it seems
that white has thrown out all his advantage out
the window because after king g8 black now has a
perpetual check idea first of all threatening mate
on f1 so that's threat number one and second
if white does something about it and plays king
c1 there will be constant checks coming queen
to a3 queen to f3 and the game ends in a draw
yeah it seemed at the end of that that was
a pretty fair result and that rook d7 move
will just highlight it one more time the point
was that the bishop gets pinned but as anna was
saying it's so hard to ever find a move like this
your king is wide open and after say queen h1 king
d2 not only is this rook hanging but you look at
queen g2 check you just are too many checks your
king's exposed it does work out for white as it
turns out but it's not an easy thing to find so
an understandable miss by martirosian but we have
to give him credit for all the way back on move
what move was that move 21 finding knight b5
that saved him the game anna exactly we were
saying how much jeffrey's position is promising
this attack on the queen side but knight b5 was
a very accurate way of defending this queenside
potential attack defending against the potential
attack by trading the knight and if black
had taken on b5 to then win the pawn on d4
white does have enough counter play by playing
bishop to c6 and later winning the pawn on d5
exactly many pawns hanging there so you will be
able to restore the material equality and keep
the unbalanced position alive it's very
difficult to see this one through the bishop on
the dark square is a strong for black but
the king isn't exactly so safe either so very
nice find there by heike martirosian and speaking
of nice finds tigran petrossian he won his game
over fabiano caruana and while the end position
is clearly dominating for black when we tuned in
it actually was very unclear with that king for
black being under attack it looked like fabiano
must have had a winning chance and the evaluation
bar shows that after king h7 the winning move was
knight g5 check king to h6 and this is where
robert you are showing to our viewers that if
knight f7 the black king can start running away
with king h5 king g4 so that wasn't the winning
line but instead of knight f7 check what white
should do here is to simply capture the pawn on
e6 and threaten now rook h8 checkmate wow because
the knight still takes away the g5 square so even
though you give black a check on d1 and things
of that nature oh my gosh rook d one check
king h2 queen uh if i could drag the piece
in the right scores queen takes e5 is check
you've f4 what a move because you're attacking
the queen and taking away the square another
time so rookie shape is unstoppable oh everything
was just working out in the end there for white
exactly i think this is what fabiano
must have missed he was down to his final
34 seconds so seeing how in the end he
can blunder the e69 with queen takes e5
check but f4 the pawn will then take care of the
g5 square and it's still a threat of checkmate
and there's no way of stopping that idea of white
this was a missed chance and after rooks even the
tables have turned and tigran petrossian managed
to take advantage of this move by slowly but
surely pushing those g pawns up the board yeah he
brought his king up which you're advised not to do
typically and then he put his queen on c4 which
was an excellent move just making sure that the
enemy queen couldn't get into the game he pushes
g5 and after rookie four starting to look a little
scary says queen d3 now the queen's come off my
king is safe and sound and your pawns are not
he ended up winning convincingly after this and
allowing armenia to tie the match and so as we
go into the next round anna we know that it's
four to four we have the next round pairings
uh ready fabiano carwana gets uh not he's not
going to play parham just yet because these are
just how many points the boards have but we know
that fabiano will take on hike marchi roshan and
parham aksudu will take on linear dominguez
in this next round and then it's going to be
wesley taking on raunch and jeffrey taking on
tigran what do you make of the current scores
what do you expect going forward give us your
thoughts well i think what we definitely need
to highlight is tigran petrossian going two
out of two he's the only player who has won
both of his games and hundred percent score
uh what a performance for board three of
the eagles and his second win was against the
world number two fabiano carrano so kudos to
tigran for carrying his team for now can
the rest of his team also start performing
more than 50 percent or less because so far it's
parham who's on 50 and marty rossian and sadwani
on half a point only that is why uh the score is
a tie but if petrochem can continue the way he
has been playing very confidently quickly and
also really strong moves on the board really
really um impressive performance today if he
goes on like that and the rest of his team
can start doing better i think the eagles have a
good chance of upsetting the archbishops who are
of course the favorites they are the
defending champions and they have a roaster
of four players above the rating of two thousand
seven hundred what's crazy about it is that tinker
petrossian is 2-0 against an average rating of
something like what 27 90 2 800. he beats linear
dominguez and five out of caruana back to back
and the road doesn't get much easier typically
you then play boards three and four and they're
much lower rated but not with the saint louis team
wesley so on board three jeffrey zhang on board
four so tigran is still the underdog despite his
perfect score thus far however armenia must be
thrilled to be tied four to four at this point
and we see the first game that's starting as
hike marty rosen with the white pieces against
uh fabiano caruana ike will need to play a better
opening this game than he did against jeffrey with
the white pieces and why don't we take our
start of the round four board view we have
three games with deep oh board four turned into
e4 it started with d4 but it turned into e4 so
once again two positions e4 openings two positions
d4 openings exactly and of course board for with
the black pieces we know that that's tigran
petrossian because he's playing his trademark
modern slash pierce defense he has been sticking
to that setup for most of his games in the protest
league doesn't matter who is his opponent he
he does believe in those openings as for the
rest of the boards i was curious what opening
will fabiano choose against d4 so his opponent
is over 200 rating points below fabiano's rating
that is a huge difference but it has been the case
with most of the match-ups of course the the
eagles are the underdogs in every single game
but it doesn't make it easier for fabiano when
the position is this symmetrical so you are the
favorite you're the one number two but your
position is almost identical to your opponent
how can fabiano create some kind of an imbalance
in this game can he try to play this for a win
not really that's the sad thing when you play
the black pieces against a strong player who
may be lower rated but still is quite talented is
it's very difficult to play for a win because now
the position is locked up hike is going to play f4
he does not want to trade on c4 because that would
open up the b file and so he's leaving the tension
alive black cannot take on e5 because after pawn
takes e5 you get forked on your queen and your
knight and so the queen slides back and i believe
anna that white can even play a4 now is waiting
for that moment this feels like the right time
because you know you're undermining the defense
of the c4 square i could be wrong i could be doing
this a little bit too quickly and instead he plays
rook c2 oh but that seems to be a blunder because
the bottom b2 can be captured if rook takes b
to rook takes c3 oh good good find there yikes
and that's the problem when you play for a
draw i think i'm pretty sure he was playing
for a draw and knight takes b2 removes
the guard and then you take on c3 next
i do think that a4 was the critical move as you
mentioned and now we can see on a hike's facial
expression that he is realizing what has he
just done to his position will fabiano play it
it's a simple tactic for such a strong player is
there and like an intermezzo with knight takes d5
or something like that saying i know i'm
going to lose this knight anyway so let me
go full on renegade here and i'll take on d5
but i think the problem ultimately is that i
take back because my queen was hanging you take
on b2 and now even though the material is even
black has outside past pawn potential this rook
can come to c3 hitting a3 putting pressure on
e3 through that bishop it doesn't feel like a very
good position for white your pawns are much weaker
yeah i agree with you that even if it's going
to be equal material after knight takes d5 rook
takes p2 this looks really good for black i
wonder why fabiano is spending that long well
oh i was looking at our analysis but
i took it for granted he took the
one he did not see it he did not see knight
xb2 or he saw a ghost line that was refuting it
wow and look at hike's face he still doesn't
look very happy but he must on the inside be
so relieved because you saw hike says he saw it he
realized that he blundered and now that he's able
to coordinate the rooks in the c file i believe in
these positions typically it's only white that can
be slightly better but maybe i'm overestimating
the chances here for white's position not that
white's even better but i think that if any
side can play for more it's typically white
absolutely and what a relief for martyrosian
who did indeed realize that he blundered with
rook to c2 fabiano didn't notice his chance
or he calculated knight takes b2 and he must
have seen a variation that was not so good for
white but he ended up believing that there was
a refutation to knight takes bt we don't know what
happened in that moment in case of fabiano was it
fully blundered the option of knight xb2 or did
he just miscalculate it in any case the current
position is back to equal hike is back in the game
and i think the best thing for fabi is if he never
at least not never but if throughout this game
he doesn't realize that he missed it because
i know it's happened to me anna when you're
playing a game you have a position you know
that something's there and you say no i i can't
deal with this let me do something else and you
can you dwell on it you're like wait i moved 12.
did i have that tactic was that there did i have
knight takes b2 oh i had knight things between
you keep thinking about it and distracts you
from the rest of the game so hopefully for fabi he
he either doesn't see it you know in this moment
or he forgets about it because he is such a
professional but still that's a huge missed
opportunity for the archbishops really big missed
opportunity and it was a simple tactical motive
for someone of the heights of fabiano that was
a move he would see in 0.1 second and he perhaps
saw it but then miscalculated let's check in
with the rest of the boards as well after this
missed chance by fabiano will there be more missed
chances on the rest of the boards what i do see
is the tigran petrossian who has been doing
very well for the egos two out of two the best
performer of the match he may be in trouble
against jeffrey zhang yeah not the type of
position that he wanted that's for sure because
you look at this position and white has control
over the d file black is trying to get control
over the c file that seems like a there's a wash
both sides are happy about their control over the
board but what the problem is here and you see
knight to d2 play to that effect is that when the
knight comes to b3 it's the a5 pawn that is the
weakest in this position so white's pawns safe and
sound black has to worry about the a5 pawn knight
b3 queen to b5 is also an option saying please
take me open up my rook on a1 to this pawn so
maybe tigran's position is ultimately fine
it just to my eyes looks better for white
but maybe i'm overstating the edge i also think
it's better for white perhaps it was even better
earlier it does feel like black is getting now
some activity for that structure weakness a5 pawn
will be a target but now with the double rooks
on the c5 maybe black is just in time to get
counter play for uh this hanging pawn on a5
for now i believe he will have to protect it
um unless he can create counter play immediately
he plays rook to b8 so is the idea after queen
takes a5 that rook a6 and the queen is just going
to c7 and that looks okay for the moment but then
you realize wait is rook c8 possible where is your
queen going from here that looks like a trap queen
yeah i think that is his idea indeed so it could
well be the case that if white takes the pawn
on a5 the most promising move forward it is
indeed a blunder because of this beautiful
motive robber that you have just spotted rook
c8 trapping the queen and it's not completely
lost for white because you could say all right
i'm losing my queen so let me take your knight
you take my queen i take your rook and you get a
rook a minor piece and a pawn temporarily for the
queen so it's not actually a losing proposition
it just is too risky especially in a team event
so we see that jeffrey says nah i don't want
any part of that i'm moving my queen back
the knight comes to b6 and that knight would like
to get into c4 while putting pressure on a4 over
here i think that tigran he's not so unhappy about
his position he's happy about his clock though
exactly he has been playing so fast in
every single game he's playing against
some of the toughest opponents in the world
he has taken down fabiano caroner just now
in round two but constantly having also
more time on the clock even when he was
in trouble with that king situation so it's
impressive to see his confidence that he keeps
the speed up even when his positions aren't the
best for now it does look like with this idea of
trapping the white queen he has managed to chase
the white queen away from b5 and the position is
less dangerous he is heading toward the c4 square
with the knight i do think that he is now back in
the game still might be better for wise slightly
better but it's not that big of a deal anymore
i'm with you and the game that has caught my eye
is the one between parham and dominguez let's go
on over there because that's a wild affair the
black king is still in the center there is a
hanging pawn on b5 it is black's turn bishop a3
can prevent black from castling this looks like
a very strange position although if b5 is captured
black is going up a pawn is it worth the pawn to
my eyes not really but dominguez is a very well
prepared player typically but parham well ahead
in the clock in this one so anna i'm throwing this
one to you it's too complicated for me right now
whose position would you prefer robert
this is such an easy question to respond to
i know the answer with hundred percent
certainty this is madness what was this opening
where's the time that dominguez has used so yeah
huge time advantage for parham and dominguez ends
up capturing the pawn so it's what you said it's
a pawn up for black but his king is still in the
middle of the board and if white manages to place
the bishop on the a3 f8 diagonal the king will get
stuck luckily for black bishop a3 you will trade
that bishop for the knight i believe knight takes
a3 has to be played in that position and then we
shall see with only queens and rooks on the board
is that enough for white to compensate for
the pawn black will manage to castle next move
right that doesn't quite seem enough for white
i know you were implying as much so maybe parham
needs to and he does it f4 and i was about to say
what about just f5 go for the brute force method
here and is f6 a threat is e6 a threat is rook
f4 swing that rook to g4 threat all of these seem
to or rook f3 i don't know which way to go to if
you move your knight maybe i have rook a3 to g3
or h3 it feels like there's so many attacking
opportunities here for white and despite the
fact that white is down the pawn i would prefer to
have parham's position here i fully agree with you
i am a huge fan of free stuff capturing pawns
but that king side looks so shaky the right
moment for pushing f6 if white finds the best
moment for that and attack further on the king
side black will have to be extremely precise
here and look at the time difference still it's
three minutes only left for linear dominguez
definitely a difficult situation the engine says
zero zero zero but this is not zero zero zero
it's anyone's game with the black king being
the main target i think perham has a good chance
because black has to be extremely accurate here
i'm with you there's no easy way to trade queens
which means it's difficult to stop the attack
we just saw the move uh f5 knight d4 was played
and well knight c2 is a threat and that is
creating a counter shot for dominguez white
can i mean there's opportunities on it to
even play bishop g5 and try to sack and go queen
g3 maybe i'm getting too excited too adventurous
uh over here but i want to checkmate the black
king that is my sole intention but i admit that
i shouldn't sacrifice all of pawns pieces in
the process it's easier for us to sacrifice his
pieces but hopefully he will not give up all
of it if he wants to succeed in this game it
does look like this is gonna be a critical
game where black will have to defend very
precisely but i also i am looking at the rest of
the board wesley so uh he has a promising position
against the 15 year old youngest member of
the field ronald sadwani i think this is a
good chance for the archbishops to score on that
board of course he is the favorite west is so but
against ronak it's not just simple to say
okay yeah i have more rating points um ronak
against the chess bros let's remind everyone did
make a draw against grishouk and beat anish giri
so he has been upsetting his opponents but i
don't think that this position is easy for rona
yeah this mission is the opposite of easy
you look at the bishop on b7 the pawn on c6
uh did i mention that pawn on b set oh yeah
the bishop that's on b7 it's doing its job of
defending the squares and a6 and c6 but it can't
do much more than that and a big problem for black
is you can't bring a knight to c4 that's typically
the way you counter a b4 d4 setup is the square in
between those pawns is vulnerable so what i would
try is knight to f7 knight to d6 knight to c4 if
you can make that happen you're very happy but
wesley's too quick he goes knight e5 which attacks
c6 and he's actually giving up a pawn on us so
would you take that pawn but give up your dark
square bishop or would you i guess just leave
the knight here and play knight f7 for instance
i think uh knight f7 is more likely but i'm
worried that if black had to take and and then
try to defend with the extra pawn maybe that
was the more accurate but less human way of
continuing the game it feels like if you open up
the position and give up the dark squared bishop
with the white bishop coming to b2 that would be
just such a scary such a dangerous position so
ronak definitely goes for the the more natural
continuation but this means that white still has
the upper hand with that c6 backward pawn being
constantly at target it's not an easy position to
break through so ronak does have good defensive
chances but he will have to be protecting this
position defending very precisely for a long time
yeah and i just brought up on the big board this
analysis what could have happened it's why he
didn't do it he didn't like the look of this
bishop on b2 the checkmating potential in the
diagonal so as we get back to the live position
he went knight f7 he is cramped he you know he's
going to just try to shuffle around and not do
anything too major but that's the good thing about
roundup's position is even though he lacks space
he's solid white has no easy way to break through
c5 can't get there every night there c6 protected
by my bishop i have my rooks in the e file not
really threatening anything in particular but just
hanging out you can give me a check on g5 great
it's a check i move my king away and from romnek's
point of view if he's thinking about getting some
sort of activity maybe there is knight f6 knight
e4 or something to that effect and he doesn't have
to just sit and wait for white to do something
he can choose to go active himself i agree
with you robert but i think we need to jump
back to tigran petrossian's game and i think he's
turning the tables again he was on the defensive
and now he has just captured a pawn on e4 meaning
that if queen takes c4 queen takes b3 black will
have a pawn knob after the trade of the
e5 phone for the a4 pawn and a very strong
b pass pawn look at this end game where tiger
and petrossian can go three out of three
oh my gosh and that was the last move so the last
couple moves you know we left off a little while
ago like back in this position and jeffrey took on
b6 and quickly tigran turned this position around
by rerouting his bishop to a more useful diagonal
trading off some pieces and said hey your e4 pawn
at the end of this needed in the defense
of your queen but so too did your knight
once it came to b3 so knight b3 looks like
a grave error and after knight takes e4
we see that t-run patrojan 2-0 to start looking to
go 3-0 and is it just miano or should this be just
can you push the pawn down or i saw the eval bar
shoot up back in favor of white i wonder why it
did shoot up jeffrey was shaking his head clearly
not happy about the current events on the board
maybe what the engine sees is a
potential counter attack so if b2
white will also start pushing the a pawn and you
want to try to trade that a pawn for the b pass
pawn of black wow that's actually an amazing line
so i'll show that so let's say black starts to b2
you're closer together queen a6 and then
you play a move like bishop to b4 saying
well you know i'm blocking you off the
problem is there's also a lot of checks right
so if this bishop comes away this king will be
susceptible to a bunch of checks so we can't just
easily get away with that and that's going to be a
big problem for black as he tries to go for a win
from the spot he needs to recognize that his
king isn't so safe and any kind of move like
h5 giving your king some more space there's a6
and after b2 there's a7 saying please have my pawn
i'll gladly take yours and then we'll reach a
position that should be easy for white to hold
incredible turn of events now in favor of jeffrey
from a lost position it does look like this is
now equal we will come back to this game later
for sure to point out where it could have been
a mesh chance by tigran right now it does
look like jeffrey is back in the game and
will manage to save half a point yeah he's needs
a claw for this one he only has a minute and 12
seconds tinkering just under three minutes but on
it sound like there's another game that has been
catching your eye absolutely the rule number two
of course we always want to tune in to the game of
fabiano caruana who has the black pieces here
against like martyrs and he did manage to win
a pawn so it's an extra pawn for black but it's
doubled pawns on the f5 not that easy to convert
it's one of these positions where black is a head
material and then sometimes white wins anyway and
now white is not better here black is certainly
better at this point but the reason i say it like
that is because you have this amazing knight on a
dark square against a bishop on a light square the
bishop cannot be an attacking piece it can only be
a defensive piece so i wouldn't even consider just
taking this knight on e4 i know that undoubles
your pawns but after king to e3 how in the world
is black going to make any progress as i have the
open file my knight is protected on c5 on a dark
square and my king blockage or past pawn i don't
see a universe where black can do much of anything
exactly this is not an easy defense to break
through what does seem to be a breakthrough though
is the wesley souls position that was a very close
setup with a c6 backward pawn which is now gone
from the board and white has managed to enter
black's camp that was an exchange sacrifice
by wesley earlier okay gonna pull up the game
between wesley soh and ronix and juani the young
star from india the young grand master he is
trying to hold off wesley so but as soon as i
tune in i see the eval bar go skyrocket and what's
going on in this position there's a queen on b7
pinning the bishop knight e6 can be played at any
moment bishop f7 for good measure winning the g6
checks this is getting pretty brutal it
is getting brutal there was an exchange
sacrifice earlier by wesley we're gonna point out
all those key moments later when we have a time to
analyze it but foreign scores a really important
point taking the lead again for the archbishops
while the rest of the boards are still underway
can the eagles strike back on any of the boards
petrossians advantage is gone while the
other two boards what do you think robert
yeah i mean tigran needed that full point he's
still going to try to fight for it but i'm looking
at this four board view in fabi's game he's now up
a second pawn but that dynamic still exists of the
bishop that's kind of questionable against a solid
knight and on board two anything can happen there
it looks like white is throwing a checkmate black
at some point oh look at that rookie seven move
is that gonna work wow i can't even evaluate it
let's go to board two between parham and whoa mate
is getting more oh my god he won on time and
delivered mate so linear dominguez loses the
game to parham maxoudlu and the score is back even
it is now five to five because saint louis won the
first game with wesley so taking down bronx iwani
but queen h6 came in threatening queen g7 mate
and if the rook came to g8 it was just rook takes
f7 and you can't stop made on h7 next you did say
that that f6 pawn push on the king side will be
critical and it won the game eventually for parham
we need to check in with the remaining two games
and we will break down all those key moments later
on for you guys but for now tigran petrossian's
game seems to be heading toward the draw by
fabian or current of course we'll be trying to
convert this to pawn advantage into a full point
yeah it looks like tiger and jeffrey they make a
draw by repetition that one's over so let us go to
fabiano versus marty rosen we have that now the
only game left familiar is up two pawns i was
making a point about the knight versus the bishop
but the knight doesn't have solid footing the king
is about to come to c5 to kick this knight out
from d4 and if that knight is forced to retreat
it does feel like fabiano is just not winning
just yet but he is well on his way to a victory
because of the two extra pawns this indeed seems
to be heading towards um a very positive finish
for fabiano who struggled in the previous round
lost his game against digra and petrossian but
is now going to win a point a very crucial
point for the archbishop that will give them
back the lead so round one so a one point lead
for the archbishops then the eagles stroke back
tied the score the archbishops are about to take
again a one point lead with one more round to go
this championship match is a nail biter i do
think that the armenian eagles have missed couple
of chances but now fabiano is converting this
engine wait don't play king c5 if there's king
city fighters rook takes b5 just the one thing
you have to watch out for uh i'm sorry i know you
were saying good points here but you just have
to watch out for night forks they're so tricky
and that's why i brought that up and i was worried
that fabiano would bring the king in he did not
and the rook came to b6 but wait a second down
with the f6 pawn now the knight comes back to d4
and can this king go b4 to c5 and is hype
turning this around was i too quick to
say that this was already over it's oh my gosh
over wait we're at seven kingdom six of king d8
there's a check meeting next wait is why is white
winning now king d6 knight c6 rook c7 checkmate
oh my gosh hike is gonna win this game ike is
going to win this game fabiano with two pawns
up in completely winning position he had a sack to
stop rooks e7 mate and now he's losing age seven
and i think he's losing this game anna you cursed
fabiano caruana you are the commentator's curse of
the round i am so sorry for cursing the players i
already have jinxed a couple of other games and i
think we lost fabiano's camera for a second or our
zoom window has moved but what we definitely have
lost to is fabiano's uh clean play in this end
game he was on his way of converting the two pawns
up into a full point and then he blundered white's
counter chances going for that checkmate pattern
i just had this feeling that dark squares would
be important even though black was up material
for a large part of this game don't play king
takes a 5 because d2 is check so in king of six
and now you could take on f5 because d2 the
d1 was not protected so he goes here first
he takes a five take the spawn you can do it 10
seconds left don't flag though i don't want to
curse both players now again so we're passing it
back to d4 and now you cannot take a f5 again so
that was a mistake that was he still needs to
move the rook again on through the d file this
might be a draw this might be true because now the
black king gets to be activated and comes to g4
wait where's this king going now oh the c3
okay so the he's gonna hold a draw with king c3
wait is it a draw wait is rook d5
and rook takes f5 happening somehow
oh my gosh this is such a complex end game
three seconds left for a fabulous d5 rook d5
and then take on f5 rook f5 you have
it because your rookie five check
if d2 and the bishops hang on c2 five seconds
he does take the pawn oh my gosh and just rook
f8 and the king can block hay this pawn and the
f pawn goes and then he's got to win this game
all over again by doing this fancy like
cutting the king off and winning the a4 pawn
such uh an incredible game with turn of events
constantly fabiano in a winning end game with
two pawns up does miss the counter chances of his
opponent then white was winning and now it still
is an advantage for white but it may not be enough
for the full point yeah this actually may already
be theoretically drawn i'm not sure because when
is upon a4 like this uh there are times when
you can try to go and win it but not when
there's this pawn on d3 so the fact that he
is not able to win this d-pawn should mean that
this position is just uh gonna be a split point
it's gonna be a draw white can take whenever he
wants to on a4 and then the pawn on d3 but he's
still trying he keeps the e file uh cut with
this rook on e8 but i don't see any chance for
white making progress so this will end up in
a draw and i honestly wouldn't i don't know if
it what fairness is in a game of chess but five
in a losing this game wouldn't quite feel right
and so i draw you know that feels like it
makes sense based on fabiano being better
throughout most of the game missing in early
knight takes b2 but still obtaining what was
a winning position and then hike receiving a gift
but not being able to put five in a car one away
we have a six six tie on a before the final
round i think this was a game where both
players are disappointed just look at their facial
expressions fabiano's smiling in the end because
he did survive a lost end game eventually but
he was completely winning earlier so both of
them blew their chances six six as you mentioned
robert we're gonna go for a short break and then
break down all the key moments from this round
because there have been so many missed chances
do
this matchup could not be any more exciting we
have a 6-6 tie heading into the final round on a
tigran petrossian he outplayed jeffrey zhang and
then unfortunately for him he missed a win with
honestly a movie should find right exactly we were
wondering how comes that he chose the a3 square
for his queen when you want to promote the b pawns
so you need to make sure that you're guarding
as many of those promoting squares promotion
squares as you can queen to a2 is way more logical
and would have been a winning move because then b3
b2 b1 there's no one that can stop the b pawn and
white's a pawn is still too slow exactly and queen
a3 makes sense and that you're connecting your
queen your bishop on the same diagonal maybe he
had ideas of bringing that bishop to b4 but quinn
a2 just the pawn pushes itself almost and that
would have been a win you see the evaluation bar
so heavily in his favor he was shaking his head at
this point recognizing that he had made a mistake
and well speaking of mistakes linear dominguez
made a pretty big one hard to fault him because
he had no time and the attack was raging on
but on at this point he made the move rook e6
and you want to tell everybody what he missed and
what parham played him is a beautiful continuation
by parham rook to e7 making sure that the queen
from b4 is now not connected to the king side
there's no more queen f8 going back so queen h6
queen g7 checkmate is the threat if black takes
the rook on e7 you just ignore it and play queen
h6 queen g7 checkmate not possible to avoid it
honestly what a beautiful tactic and it's one
that i remember when i first learned of things
like this your instinct is well if i give you
my rook and you take it i'm taking it right back
but then you know when i was a kid i was
taught hey you don't always have to recapture
and here's a great example of that the rook
on e7 says your queen is not coming to f8
and black probably should have played queen f8
himself just making sure that there's no queen
h6 no queen e7 checkmate but rookie six trying
to pile up pressure on the pawn here rookie
seven takes away your option and as the game
continued uh he did not take on e7 but it didn't
matter because there was no way to stop the queen
from getting to h6 and once the queen got here
there's no stopping now rook takes f7 since your
king had to go to the corner and nice finish there
for parham max beautiful finish that checkmate
pattern rook e7 blocking the queen of black and
for that reason it seems that instead of rookie
six black should have played perhaps queen to f8
willingly going back to make sure that there will
be no mate ideas on g7 exactly sometimes the more
passive move is the correct one and here seems to
be an example that still would have been difficult
especially with the clock situation but lenier
loses this game he's having a really tough day and
parham as he gets ready for his matchup against
fabiano carwana he's likely in a much better mood
absolutely and speaking of the world number two
he also missed his chances he had two pawns up
in an end game against hike marti russian let's go
back robert to the moment where he missed white's
counter chances and the white king coming in to
black scam threatening checkmate for sure i mean
the rook came into b6 with check the black king
actually walked backwards and here king c5 was
just crushing because now the rook is under attack
and if you make a move like rook takes f6 black
has moved d4 check if your king goes to b2 i play
d3 i win your knight if your knight captures the
pawn i have rook e3 check and then my king takes
your knight on d4 i go up a piece and win the game
instead what happened with fabiano is after the
rook came into b6 with check he retreated his king
and then all of a sudden he grabs another pawn
but in comes white's army the king came into c5
and the king on c7 lacks defenders and it
should have been a win at this point for
hike martie rossian but unfortunately he forgot
he missed he didn't have enough time to calculate
the consequences at precisely this moment of king
takes f5 because d2 d1 is no longer defended the
bishop would need to be on c2 to make that work
and thus white wins this pawn and wins the game
yes both miss their winning chances which
eventually led to a draw i think overall a
fair result since both players had their moments
in this game meaning that both martyrossian and
fabiano karana could be very disappointed of the
result at the very end of course it was fabiano
escaping with the draw so we did see the world
number two smiling but overall not a good day
for fabi not at all when we bring up the pairings
and the standings at this point you see that board
one plays board one two versus two three versus
three and four versus four and as you look across
the pairings here to me what stands out of course
is leonardo dominguez with just half a point but
also tigran patrocian two and a half out of three
for the armenian eagles but his counterpart wesley
so is also having a good day exactly those two
will face each other now in the final round lena
dominguez has been a weak spot in the archbishop's
team today ronak said one is also on half a point
but he is the lowest rated player of the field
he did beat any giri andrew alexander grishik
when they faced the chess bra so we know that he's
more than capable of upsetting his opponents but
so far he hasn't managed to score this final
round will decide everything it's six six it's
a tie with four more games to go this is the final
round if we do see a tie after these four games
we will go into the tiebreaker robert would you
like to remind our viewers in case it's eight
eight what happens what is the tiebreaker system
absolutely if it there is an 88 tie we get into a
ladder system which means that board four plays
against board four and then the winner moves on
while the loser is eliminated and you go up to the
enemy board one it's kind of the boss stage and it
is a three minute plus one second increment blitz
time control so you'll have to move more quickly
you could lose some time much more readily so you
have to take that into account for these teams if
there's a situation down the stretch of this match
here will you want to play in the blitz i think
and they're going to be safe rather
than taking too many risks and anna
looking at our four board view i see three
e4 games this round three of them it's a new
force wesley was a bit late to the start of his
game but now he is back and already blissed out
his opening moves i do see a berlin on board two
that will not be the most exciting but dominguez
hasn't had the best of his day so far and now
it's perhaps more comfortable having entered
a very theoretical line he this is already
his second game in the berlin today
it is indeed in well we're typically not too
excited by the berlins he got a worse position
it felt like against ronald sedwani in the second
game but linear is a stellar opening theoretician
he has been a second of fabiano caruana who was
sitting right next to him on the camera there and
so he knows what he's doing typically but i don't
know his play today leaves a lot to be desired
most certainly he is not happy with his
performance we shall see if in the final
round he manages to play better or perform better
for his team so far it hasn't been his day fabiano
karna also cannot really be too happy about his
performance today but he does have the white
pieces in this final game against parham maxillo
the former world junior champion and this is still
a very theoretical line where y does take more
space in the center but black is ready to strike
back with c6 and then go for a knight maneuver
towards c5 right and black can trade at some
moment and keeping the pawn tension is a lesson
that is very difficult for most people to learn
because why don't i take on c4 why don't i take on
d5 parham says i'm not taking either of those and
part of the reason why is if he had taken on c4
and the pawn would have taken back they would open
the a4 square for this bishop so just to show that
example very quickly that if you trade on c4 it
helps white more than it can help black by giving
this bishop on c2 another diagonal to reroute
itself to so just a consideration there are um
pushing his pawn forward rather than capturing
and the bishop came out to e3 so ana they're sort
of shuffling their pieces trying to figure out the
right setup i typically prefer white's position in
these lines but what do you make of things so far
i do like having more space as well it's cozy
for white also way easier for maneuvering with
your pieces regrouping your pieces to find the
most active squares for them at the same time
it's a very close position and white will
manage to find the right way to strike will
we see a knight coming to g3 and f5 will we see
something on the queen side in the right moment
there are so many traits possible b4 could
be pushed at some point many open questions
yeah i mean i i wish i had the answers to all them
this is less of a theoretical discussion more of
a strategic discussion which setup do you want
to employ here and bishop a6 play so instead of
playing b4 first starts with bishop to a6 which
opens up the queen on the b file can also allow
queen of b7 in case you need to connect the rooks
that could be useful and so i do think that harhom
knows what he's doing he is just sitting patiently
in this position understanding that white has
slightly more space but black does not have any
really serious weaknesses d6 is protected there
are no sacrifices on h6 so all in all i think
that parham is okay with his current position
i think so i think this is so far um an equal
position or slightly better for fabiano but
still barham being um i think very accurate
this is move order and finding the right
continuations i would like to take a look at
the rest of the boards as well just to have
a quick idea of what's going on on the rest of the
boards i'm just swiping through the remainder of
the position stigra and petrossian who has been
performing very well for the eagles he is the mvp
definitely for armenia two and a half points
out of three almost three out of three had he
won that end game in the previous round here with
the white pieces though does he have an actually
good position i'm not sure you are highlighting
those minor pieces robert i think for a reason
i am because even though the evaluation bar says
black is to be preferred it's easier or just more
natural to think of the sacrifices in the position
for white to think of the ways to break forward
and what is this knight back to h2 is g4
g5 on the docket here and how does black
make progress i would say d4 to open up this
bishop on a b7 that's one serious way that
i would consider playing for black but other
than that i'm not seeing the same exact threats
as white is trying to achieve so i think it's
easier to play often from white's perspective
but wesley so he's been playing the french
defense for such a long period of time now
he's one of the best players in the world
he's also two and a half and a three
so he knows what he's doing and tigran is happy to
be in this position based on his clock management
absolutely this is the board three clash with
two of the best performing players both wesley
saw antigram petrossian being the top performer
for their teams definitely it will be a decisive
factor for the overall score of the match what
will happen in this game i'm just looking at
g4 g5 i don't know how black stops it i don't
know if it's possible to stop it but maybe i am
tunneling a little bit too much i just know that's
what's coming up next most certainly we're going
to see g4 g5 and wesley shall take a decision
whether to push d4 in the center open up the long
diagonal what will be hispane he has to go for
something active speaking of active i think that
dominguez has improved his position out of
the opening so if we can just give a quick
update on that seemingly boring start with the
berlin now why it does have really active pieces
yeah look at this rook h1 move trying to take
over the h file and don't be fooled black cannot
castle because the early queen trade forced the
black king to take on d8 and then come back to e8
and rook g8 is typical because if you traded
rooks then you have a problem both h8 and h7
now only h7 is available to white's rook and this
black king can slide over to f8 if need be i also
prefer white's position anna but i'm not quite
certain how to proceed from here is black going
to play bishop c5 and try to get opposite colored
bishops by taking this knight on d4 is black going
to play c5 and give the c6 square to this light
square bishop and claim hey maybe i can even try
to gain an advantage here it's not so easy to
see how white makes the progress that we know he
wants to with f4 and f5 and things of that nature
absolutely robert it does seem still more pleasant
for white but as you pointed out it's not so easy
to make actual progress so by optically it looks
great for white it may not be a simple task to get
more out of this slightly better position slightly
better maybe also on board for their position or
just completely equal i can't tell for now it it
does look close to being equal the game between
ronix advani and jeffrey jean that's the last game
we haven't looked at the two youngest participants
of the finals fifteen-year-old ronaldo with the
white pieces against nineteen-year-old jeffrey
zhang okay pulling it up now i see that okay it's
not a symmetrical pawn structure and white has
these double pawns in g2 and g4 but those seem
more pleasant than they could possibly be bad
having a semi-open h-file the g4 pawn stops any
kind of mobility for black's pawns and let me ask
you on i don't really see a way for black to even
think about making progress here but how does
white try to make progress in a position like this
white seems to be trying to making progress
by offering a draw in this moment if i see it
correctly ronald said when he has offered
a draw so the question is will jeffrey
take it or try to play this for a win i'm sure
that he also will be looking at the rest of the
boards how are they doing in terms of the match
if i'm jeffrey i have plenty of time left i'm not
even thinking about the draw for the next three
minutes i'm studying my teammates games and
in doing so i may get myself some time trouble
if i need to play on but at least i know whether
or not i have to play on because the position from
an objective lens here is probably slightly better
for white nothing major but i don't really see
how black is the one who's making progress here
so if white is slightly better and i have a draw
on the table let me study my teammates games very
closely and then that will help me determine
whether or not i should accept the half point
exactly it's so important to take into account the
rest of the boards this is a team competition and
the team that will score two and a half points
in this round will be the champion so every
half point matters i think jeffrey is possibly
doing exactly what you have just said robert
so why don't we do what jeff is doing with our
four board view just to see all games at once
and no jeffrey did make a move but you know he's
looking at all the boards he moved his knight to
b6 i still believe that white is slightly better
he probably had his eyes on board two not i'm
sorry boy three between wesley so and teagan
petrossian not quite sure who's better and why
with black advancing on the queen side and white
advancing on the king side the berlin game between
dominguez and uh hike marti rosen okay nothing
major just yet and then board one you always
trust fabiano carwana but i'm not sure you quite
trust him today after his performance thus far
yes unfortunately it hasn't been the best of
days for the world number two but jeffrey did
decline the draw and is trying to play that rook
and game um whether for a win or just to keep
the game going for now i think it's more about
keeping the game going with logical active moves
but there isn't that much in his endgame shall we
go back to board one and see if fabiano is making
any progress let's do that and i have the position
up white is just more active in pretty much every
single way the bishop on d3 queen on e2 hitting
this pawn on b5 that's clearly making black's
pieces passive defensive tied down to that pawn
whereas whites are putting pressure but usually
you need a second avenue of attack right and where
is that going to come from for fabiano caruana
i'm not sure where there will be a chance for
fabiano to keep making progress i do think this
is a promising position but as you already
highlighted robert not that simple to keep
bringing more forces in i do think that if he if
he finds a way to bring the f1 knight into the
game that would be great that's still is due to be
improved he pushes h4 to fix the pawn structure on
the king side and maybe to push g4 in the right
moment i do like that idea i do as well and we
we're just talking about a second avenue of attack
g4 is quite a straightforward attacking approach
and the good news for white is knight on seat six
cannot be kicked out it also stops this queen from
ever getting to d4 will try to poke and prod in
white's position and so rook a8 look at parham
going back and forth back and forth doesn't
really have any actual plan the knight on a4
can't move the bishop on a6 is tied to defense of
b5 the bishop on h6 has nowhere to go and now the
essential question is is g4 a good move or is it
overly risky for some reason for now fabiano says
g3 is better he still wants to improve his pieces
and then push g4 in the right moment he does have
the luxury of deciding when he wants to push to
get his position ready and also from the corner
of my eye i'm staring at tiran petrossian's
position because he's going for that kingside
attack that he already announced long ago robert
there has been a trade of pawns on the king side
and what is going on my head hurts just trying
to evaluate this white is missing a pawn on a2 so
wesley is losing in exchange if tigran wants it
but the bishop on h4 may just be stronger than
the rook on e7 but he did steal this pawn on a2
which is very dangerous down the line as it keeps
the a1 rook tied down to the defense of this pawn
promotion the knight on c3 can't easily be kicked
i prefer white's position still i believe in the
attacking chances more so than i believe in the
eventual you know promotion of a pawn and i'm
looking at a way to get my rook to g1 not now
um at least i don't think so but somehow rook to
g1 move my king to h3 and open up this g-file go
for an attack that's just where my head's at right
now i'm with you robert absolutely the evaluation
of the engine is zero zero zero but when you see
this massive king side aggression of white with
the rook coming to the g5 and the reason why the
engine evaluates this as equal is due to that a3
past form that black has so material wise black is
ahead and does have a protective pass bomb but he
will have to defend so precisely on the king's
side to survive that attack i think petrossian
has great practical chances to win this
game oh indeed and another idea is bishop
f6 not just taking this work on e7 but i think
wesley the smart thing bringing the knight back
to d5 covering the f6 square queen e4 check is
possible does nike come into d6 if you want it's
getting very sharp here and i do prefer white's
position i made that loud and clear at this point
but i am not positive that there's a way to really
crash through it just made it look better than it
actually is absolutely i'm also just switching
back and forth through the rest of the voice
because this is the final round every single board
matters so let's take a look at all four boards
at the same time lania dominguez has just pushed
f6 which will be a move that we'll need to analyze
but it does seem that he's taking the initiative
and has good chances to finally score because he
hasn't been doing very well he only made a
draw so far overall as well as that position
that we already looked at well the rukan game
perhaps is the least exciting where jeffrey
declined a draw ronald said he offered a draw
earlier it still seems to be an equal position
but the rest of the board geez uh robert what
do you think where should we go first i think we
should start with the ronix sidwani game because
i'm actually a little bit worried for jeffrey he
declined to draw before but now i see this king
over here on a3 and i understand that rounduk is
going to play b4 and the outside pass pawn could
be a really big deal and he plays b4 very quickly
and yeah the eval is going up for better for white
back to level but i think practically speaking
playing with an outside pass pawn is scary to me
and you just know that ronic wants to keep pushing
these and b pawns exactly and he also has quite
some time advantage two minutes of difference
between the time management of these two players
so will jeffrey regret declining the draw now
he has to fight for a draw in this endgame still
should be possible to defend but not the simplest
of tasks for sure and i think that jeffrey's being
very smart not to take on b4 because if you take
on b4 you give two passers whereas now if white
ever takes an a5 that doesn't look very good you
have these double isolated pawns granted
it's a pass pawn but it looks like you
won't survive too long and if you play b5 then
this king comes into c5 stopping your pawn
in its tracks and you only have one past
pawns i think jeffrey is doing the right thing
by leaving the tension over here as white
does not especially want to take on a5
exactly i'm also quickly taking a look at lanier's
position after ethics f6 check he did play rook
h5 which seems to be a very promising move if
we go to his board for for a moment after rook
h5 he was threatening bishop g5 check picking
up the rook on d8 so the rook had to be moved
oh and actually rookie e8 hangs the bishop on
d7 but attacks the bishop on e3 and the event
of rook takes d7 here's this is happening isn't c7
hanging but c2 will be hanging it feels like white
is first to the action here and should be better
but how much better honor good question will
we see the capture of the c7 pawn i think that's
likely a rook f5 check 2 is promising depending on
what's the follow up there for black can he
go king g6 or hes or king e6 is more precise
this isn't that easy for sure for martyrosian who
is below two minutes now and the one thing i would
say that hike has that he should keep in the back
of his mind here is if he loses his four pawns
for white's three pawns and trades a pair of
rooks that should be a theoretical draw so
what i'm saying is if you just get rid of all
these pieces that are highlighting in red that
this position remaining should be a theoretical
hold for black so he knows that that's the case
which means that he could try to just take all
these queenside pawns even if it cost him his
and then he'll try to hold the position from
there because otherwise i think his position
is far more risky i fully agree with you this
will be a difficult rooken game still but with
the potential idea of trading all queenside pawns
for then a theoretical draw if you also get to
trade one pair of ropes this is a good practical
chance but we shall see how it plays out in this
actual moment i am looking at fabian or karena's
game again because i do think he has been making
lots of progress okay so one last thing i want
to show in this game very quickly and i see the
international master teddy coleman's in the chat
king g6 your qe6 king g6 could have been a mistake
because after king g6 rook c7 check take on c2
there's rook c6 and then rook h5 checkmate because
your king has forced the h file and you get
checkmated immediately so that was a really clever
sequence which is why hike martie rosen in the
game brought his king closer to the center which
came to e6 but now we can go to uh fabiano's
game because anna you are telling us that father
is making progress right i just got really
excited from the fact that it feels like now
even though that knight looks funky on a5 that
does mean that this there's something happening
on the c5 at the same time do we actually want
to trade the rooks or really just jump back to c6
shut down the c file and then push g4 because
i have been waiting for the g4 push for so long
when is it the right moment for g anyway it's
possible that he's not going to play g4 and he's
just going to win this pawn on b5 and i'm with
you i want to play g4 too it looks like the just
way to go for the attack he's saying let me be
positional and steal this b5 pawn in some way
but after bishop takes b5 there maybe knight
c3 you have to look out for tactics like that
i'm not quite sure that everything is in
order for fabiano but what's not in order
is his clock on a his position may be great but 40
seconds of counting down that spell some trouble
he keeps going really low on time he is
not as confident as he usually is today
hasn't been the best of days for him so
he is second guessing his moves pawn up
for fabiano but there is a slight issue with the
fact that if you move away to b5 knight then the
b4 pawn will always be hanging after the trade
on d3 and he's going down to 17 seconds right now
oh no oh no you can't afford to get down to your
seconds like this what's he doing he needs to move
he really needs to move i think he's forgetting
about his clock honestly okay plays knight to
a3 but takes and queen takes b4 and the worst is
behind black like i've just won the poem back this
is what we said that the the knight could not be
moved for this reason it's equal material now and
10 seconds for fabiano there's a two second
increment but moving off of the increment
exactly uh he has won the pawn back
and now has activated the queen so
it is now black who starts having chances and he
is 5.1 seconds left parham is three minutes on the
clock i'm worried you know the queen e1 is under
attack right now but after queen c1 there's knight
c5 to come it doesn't feel so easy robert sorry
i need to cut you off because tigran has just
won with a beautiful checkmate we i think have
missed the moment but it's it has just happened
okay we'll just stay here because [ __ ] has
3.8 seconds left but we'll definitely show you
tigran petrossian's win and wow what a result
for our meeting eagles bishop b2 if i know had
0.8 seconds when he made that move king g7 what's
he going to do queenie 2 back and how does black
make progress the position is better for parham
here but ana how do you actually break through
well at this stage does he have to make progress
though if patricia has won taking the lead for the
eagles can they just go for draw in every other
board that could be the case because ronak has
already made a draw against jeffrey zhang so
the question will be if lania can win it but
that's an equal rook and game he may just need
a draw per hour max may just be ready for a draw
oh my gosh and it's all because tigran
petrossian has been the hero of the day
i'm going to flip very quickly to the
other game that we have still going between
haike martirosian and leonard dominguez as you
were saying it should be a draw rook takes f3
check and you have checks galore rook g3 rook f3
back and forth i don't think there's anything that
linear can do to even try to win this game he
might lose the game more quickly than he wins
it let's go back to karawana versus maksudlu
because that game still has plenty left up in
the air i think that fabiano will try desperately
he'll try to claw for a victory but i imagine that
parham objectively is in no danger of losing this
game absolutely no danger and he still has time
to look at the rest of the boards and see that
his team is winning i'm not sure that fabiano
will manage to do so or he has to use parham's
time to try to glance at what's going on on the
rest of the boards but yes this is the case the
world number two in a must-win situation if he
wants to tie the score for the archbishops uh oh
but he's dropping his e4 pawn with check to boot
and that's an extra pawn for parham maksulu the
eagles the eagles how are they doing this they
look like they were on paper were just huge under
they looked like they were dead in the water after
the first match down two and a half one and a
half i really thought st louis was going to keep
cruising but somehow the eagles are taking this
championship unless something goes extremely wrong
here for parham max tsuba it is insane they have
been the underdog in the top four in the finals
again this year but they are proving that the odds
don't matter for them what a team comedy it's not
official yet but it does look like the eagles if
they draw these final two games that are underway
they will be the champions they are taking down
the defending champions saying with archbishops
and i don't think parham maksubi is going to even
entertain the question of a comic he's going to
win this game he is pushing for a win fabiano
has no time here's queen f3 check this king on uh
g2 is in big trouble i would even consider
moves like king to h6 first just to get the
king out of any sort of checks maybe even
h4 and then queen f3 and g3 there must be
something here for parham muksu i'm not quite
sure what it is but knight d2 what a tricky move
knight of three check and you have to cancel
king g2 because queen takes d3 wins the night
exactly i think he will give the check no he
pushes h4 instead and now he will go for knight f3
g3 instead queen f1 and knight f3 is made if we
take it so what's going on here so queen queen f3
or queen h3 one of these queens three that's
probably a mating net after queen h3 you're
threading knight f3 checkmate or queen h2 and if
you take on g3 the queen just takes back on g3
this should be a win for parham monk sudlu this
is insane the evaluation by showing mate in six
how did they do it robert oh my goodness queen
takes g3 oh queen of one knight of three is
me look at perhaps celebrating it the armenian
eagles are the champions of 2020 the pro chess
league once again the underdogs take over and look
at them that is pure jubilation they are ecstatic
parham with the biggest smile on his face i
don't even know is ronak is just he just just
fist bumped and hike and tigran they left
their respective computers but you know that
is celebration time for the armenia eagles what
an epic finish it was for them and parham maksulu
with not just the draw that he needed with a
victory over world number two fabiana karwan
at the end there and hike martirosian he is in
disbelief he's just laying back in his chair
what a finish of this regular not the regular
season the playoffs the entire season of the pro
chess league absolutely epic finish and you know
what else is epic robert because we thought this
was all parham maxillo taking down fabiano winning
the match but hike martirosian won a dead draw
rook and game 2 against lanier dominguez if we
bring up his game i have no idea how he did it
but he also won might be the case of course that
dominguez knew that he's in a muslim situation
but after all this is now a dominant score
nine and a half six and a half for the eagles
what a finish that was we could do this all
day we could look at all the games we'll save
that for the news reports because we need
to get set up for a post-match interview
with the absolutely jubilant the thrilled i
mean it's just you can't say enough positive
words with the armenian eagles we'll take a quick
break when we return we'll have all four players
for an interview hear their thoughts and just
hear how relieved they must be after taking down
this super gm lineup from the st
louis archbishops we'll be right back
so
well we were having a great time with the
pro chess league champion armenia eagles
huge congratulations to you all hike i just have
to start with you you know your captain artak
manookian called you the engine of the team and
you had a huge save today against fabiana carwana
in the third match how did you hold that together
and what do you think it meant for your team
yeah i think we are playing today super bad
and my position against fabiano was uh the
debut i played very bad but in the last moment
i winning position when i played the rook d4
and he played bishop b5 but i
didn't zero game for a draw k4 with
my position is notable yeah well you held
it together we're really happy because our
opening this very strong thing definitely the case
but you have some strong players and well tigran
i mean you were the hero today what did you eat
for breakfast what are you doing how did you score
three and a half out of four against such a
monstrous lineup actually uh during the match i
was drinking the gin all the time so as usual you
guys should know how i'm playing okay i'm retired
chess player but i i like blitz and rapid so
usually i'm playing not bad in this kind of stuff
so i'm happy that i could help my team because in
the first few i mean before qualifications rounds
i was i was playing not so good and the guys
was winning and i was trying to keep not to lose
and okay i'm happy that in the final i could i
could come back and help the team well three and
a half out of four is certainly not bad and now
you're seeing it i'm upset i have winning physique
in the rest game so it looks like i should
have something after queen b2 so i'm not
sure but i i have a feeling that it should be
winning but i i just i was surprised that after
queen a3 b2 it's it's hope looks
like it's old i didn't find anything
to you i would like to ask you about this
final moment uh did you see that your team
was already leading when you managed to win
the b pawn back against fabian or carolina
and when did you decide that a draw was
not enough for you you won the full point
point was uh i saw uh hayek results uh wrong i
thought that he lost the game and i should win uh
and my win will help our team to win the match i
didn't know that he won this game and yeah i think
that gives me some uh fighting spirit
to play with for win against fabiano
oh that explains we just thought you want
to win because your position is better now
no no no i was very okay with draw but i
thought that my win will cause our champion
and you know rauner today you know you
had a tough day a tough slate of opponents
maybe you didn't score as much as you would like
but the semifinals you were a hero for the team
you had a plus score against another super strong
team so what was it like for you playing for the
armenian eagles and scoring so well and being
such an integral part of this championship team
yeah it was pretty good experience okay first
of all i would like to thank kartha for giving
me this chance yeah there are many other guys who
could play so yeah in the semi-finals i was in a
pretty good shape today also i was playing well
but the oppositions were much more stronger so
yeah yeah but you i mean you performed
very well it's not easy to take on board
four responsibilities but uh you did what
you need to do to help this team get to the
final and then secure the victory so i mean you
deserve like all you do huge uh congratulations
yeah last draw was i think important for the
team because they got some more confidence
exactly that was getting you guys closer to the
end of the match with tigran's win there i was
curious about how did you prepare for today's
match knowing that you are going into this match
again as the underdog you're facing the top-rated
team all of them are above 2700 with the world
number two sitting on board one so what do you do
to have the confidence and faith that you can win
the match actually uh i would like to say a few
words uh maybe parham and raunak didn't know that
uh but okay today it was a moment that
i was thinking even not to play because
uh in about maybe 12 hours ago now armenia is
in a wire situation if you didn't know the news
so we got attacked by azerbaijan i don't want
to talk more about politics but okay it was a
moment and now it's very bad situation
in the borders but okay we consider to
play and okay what to do we cannot change the
schedule i believe and i said okay let's play
and i'm happy that we won and i just want that air
all this stuff will finish as soon as possible and
no other people will not die because we have news
that from both sides there is a lot of that so
okay that's enough about politics i just this is
the answer how i prepared from the early morning
we start about all these news and i i just didn't
want to play at all but okay i said okay let's
try to do it we are very sorry to hear that and i
certainly wasn't aware of that piece of news i i
hope that things will uh go back to peace as soon
as possible and i hope everyone will stay safe
and other other i i just play blitz and bullet
games in chesscomb earlier so i'm not playing so
often now so i said okay let's play a little bit
have some practice okay i think it helped me yeah
and i mean you continue to be an inspiration for
your country i know that i mean armenia has such
a rich chess history and tigran well you
in particular you have a pretty important
name so uh what do you think that a result like
this can do for armenia more broadly and for the
chess culture that already is quite rich in your
country yes this is also some kind of traditional
tradition i mean we have armenian eagles team who
this team is i'm playing first year from this team
but okay they already won once so i'm happy that
our chess in armenia is going up and up again of
course our hopes most of them with levon arunian
who will whom maybe have chance to fight for a
title but still i i'm happy with every single
i mean winning it will it can be some just
championship under 18 16 some i don't know rapid
and bleach european cups and anything and anywhere
where armenian will win i will be very happy
and i'm happy that i can do my i can do myself
i mean i can be part of this as well for sure
and uh you know it's very well said and you
know it shows how close of a team in a country
you are when it comes to the chess successes
of which there are many and well parham you know
you're from iran you also have a country that is
very quickly improving in the broader chess scene
so what is um you know what are your thoughts
about the pro-chess league and uh will we see a
strong team from iran in the future do you think
unfortunately ali is uh left so uh we don't
have uh real chances to get some medal or
anything else in olympia because i think
if i another uh was playing our team
in next two three years we had very good chance
uh even to get medals in olympia and uh for
purchase league i think uh i can do my best for
any iranian team if they offer me but i prefer to
play in team which can uh be in top teams and yeah
i can't do better when i play in a stronger team
we're happy to have you parham with us veronica
i was going to ask you a similar question because
there are so many strong teams in india as well
do you see yourself competing next next season to
for the armenia eagles or do you think that some
of the indian teams will try to sign you now i
think i will stick to armenia because of my very
close friend and coach who is also a brilliant
chess player and all my friends who played today
so i think i'll stick to our menu that's a great
answer and of course we should give a shout out
to seven andressian sean sergio and they have been
doing so well during the season for the armenian
eagles and the captain artak manookian obviously
and i have one final question before i let you
all go and celebrate and that's for hike and for
parham you are teammates today but it looks like
you are opponents i think as soon as tomorrow in
the junior speech championship so hike i'll start
with you are you ready to take on parham even
though today he's such a good friend and helping
your team reach the championship and win the title
and i'm happy for uh uh he plays our team in our
mini eagles and i want to say thank you you play
very good and i'm also happy for i'm playing with
him in gcc grand prix because he is a very strong
player uh either he's been games and for me it's
very good parham that he's a very nice guy i
think that's his way of saying you played great
but i hope you don't play so great against me
okay i played in iranian league
we also i wanted to say that
yes because hike is uh my best friend uh hike and
aurum hakubian or my best friend from armenia and
also he played uh iranian league in our team
and we were roommate there i think this will be
very great match and uh i like to play with hike
because he's very strong blitz player and i think
the most important thing is to play fair and keep
friendship as well so i think this will be a very
great match wow you two are too nice yeah i also
wanted to thanks them for trusted me to play in
semi and final because uh i didn't play so much uh
previous rounds and i didn't help team to qualify
i mean because zaven and sean played brilliant
for quite for qualify to this round but
they trust me and they let me to play in semi
and final so i thank them a lot thank you too
thank you well we thank all of you for joining us
we congratulate you once again the armenia eagles
are the champion of the 2020 pro chess league so
thank you so much to you for and congratulations
thank you guys for working for all this
time yeah thank you to i believe you you
were supporting armenian eagles right anna i do
have i do okay i got this from artak with my face
on it i have a moment from the armenia eagle so
how can i not support you guys i've been bribed
robert i will bring you armenian cognac next
time i'll come to usa oh i mean you know the
bribes are real they're everybody here of course
when i was in armenia a couple years ago i had
dinner with most of the chess players their
hike was there so i'm very appreciative of
armenia's very generous spirit uh i really
enjoyed my visit there so hopefully um you know
everything gets better as you were saying t-run
and we wish you all the best hopefully got help
thank you thank you congratulations again and
that means that the armenia eagles win the protest
league for the second time and the archbishops the
defending champions going down today against the
army nagos both of them out of the four seasons
of the protest league have won two times the two
champions and what odds that they overcame
to win this championship parham and raunch
appreciative just to be in the lineup hike and
tigran such a mainstay of these armenian eagles
especially hike he was referred to as the
engine that really the team was built around
and he performed when he had to down the stretch
he held off fabiano caruana even from a losing
position and he even beat linear dominguez and
should have been a draw likely objectively but
then he ended up winning that game as well so what
an all-around performance from those four stars
they were lower rated on paper in both pairings
and semis in the finals and yet they are your pro
chess league champions indeed congratulations
again to the armenia eagles i'm sure that
the captain artak manukian will be celebrating
it with the team at least in a video call but
we should also reveal what's to come because the
protest league 2021 is already being organized
for next season and the price fund ladies and
gentlemen we have a hundred thousand dollars
at stake that is twice as much money as we had for
the prices for this season wow and the pro chess
league and the world of chess continues to grow it
is a very international game we saw today a team
from the united states team from armenia we've
had teams from all across the globe it's such a
great league to have and well anna the season has
come to its conclusion that makes me a little sad
to say that it's been going on for so long and
it's been such a pleasure having the call for the
finals with you likewise robert always a pleasure
to be working with y'all be sad that there will
be no more matches but as you said the junior
speeches championship is underway there will be
more chess.com events coming up hopefully
pogchamps number three as well i'm
i'm so waiting for that too because it has been
a blast to be working with some of the creators
and streamers from other categories as well other
fields and backgrounds um i think there's a lot
to come for chess when it comes to esports online
competition so stay tuned for the upcoming events
the junior speech championship all these days
these upcoming weeks and from then on you guys
will definitely see some announcements that will
amaze you and hopefully we'll see you guys back
here at chess.com on chess tv at the twitch.tv
slash chess wherever you guys can find us
um we do want to thank all of you who tuned in
for today all this weekend and for the season
because it started out back in january yeah it was
quite a long time ago and i just want to reiterate
the thanks that ana just gave it really is an
honor for us to commentate in front of all of
you you make this possible you make it so much
more fun our team behind the scenes who have just
been working tirelessly on the production making
the value of it so high i've really been impressed
i have no part in how this looks except for myself
and i just i'm so appreciative of the effort put
in and it really pays off and of course to
chess.com for sponsoring this league for
helping grow the game of chess and well i
think danny's gonna be happy with this sign
off because i'm gonna relax for now i was gonna
say you need to stretch show up with that t-shirt
oh danny i hope you're happy wherever you
are but thank you so much for what was a
great season everybody we're gonna send a raid
over to nemo and enjoy more chess the protesting
will continue in 2021 but until then you have to
get your fill elsewhere see everyone see you soon
you